e
oh okay let's uh kind of get started we
will start with
um our first bill HP uh 105 creating a
new conservation license plate and
directing the additional fee to the
crinian bacteria mitigation load and
Grant fund and the chair would like to
recognize uh the sponsor Rose uh
representative Rong welcome to
Transportation
representative thank you very much Mr
chairman and thank you every everyone um
I'm very pleased to introduce HB 105 FN
it is to provide a non-tax revenue
source for the cyanobacteria mitigation
loan and Grant fund which is managed by
the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services as you may be
aware toxic cyanobacteria blooms are
increasing in frequency and duration
throughout the world including New
Hampshire lakes ponds and rivers they
threaten the health of people and
animals and risk billions of dollars in
value created by our Lakes controlling
the occurrence of cyanobacteria blooms
is complicated and
expensive although we can't directly
control the warming of water which
drives the prevailance of blooms we can
control the nutrients which feed CYO
bacteria blooms specifically phosphorus
and
nitrogen to to do this Dees and lake and
Watershed associations rely on water
body specific studies to identify the
source of nutrients which enter a lake
or are embedded in the
sediment these studies referred to as
watershed management plans or Watershed
based plans come at a cost raging from
$50,000 and up among the plans
deliverables are theide identification
of specific projects to mitigate
nutrient loading which may include
Culvert replacement or maintenance
runoff diversion revation of
Shoreline and Shoreline septic system
replacement and so
on sometimes if the nutrients are
entering the water column from the
sediment an in Lake treatment may be
required to control
blooming Dees uses watershed management
plans to assist it in determining which
projects receive available
funding all these projects come at a
cost that can range from several
thousands of dollars to hundreds of
millions of dollars Dees Awards funding
to support Watershed water quality needs
through Section 319 of the EPA matching
grants and section
604b but these these total less than
half a million per year and I'm sure the
folks from DS will correct me if I'm
that but that's far less than the
current need for example the Lake Winn
pasak Alliance has identified 270
mitigation projects with 50 completed to
complete all of them for this Lake would
require more than $9 million and those
are just projects that are identified
now that haven't been identified through
watershed management planning that's in
process or planned in the future when
the cyano bacteria mitigation loan and
Grant fund was established in
2023 it initially received $1 million
from the general fund it received
another 500,000 from arpa funds and
500,000 from
Surplus most has already been spent we
need a sustainable source of funding to
address this growing need of
cyanobacteria blooms the love New
Hampshire Lakes Conservation plate which
is proposed in HP
105 also known as The Loon plate will
meet a tremendous need in the state by
generating sustainable non-tax Revenue
to help address the growing problem of
toxic cyanobacteria blooms it's
uncertain how much revenue will be
generated annually but the Moose plate
program has generated over $30 million
since its Inception in
2001 that is over $1 million per year if
the Loon plate generates even half this
much it will help us respond and
mitigate the threat toxic cyanobacteria
blooms pose poses to the health of our
people animals environment and economy
it will also help us raise awareness
that new New Hampshire Lakes are a
Priceless resource to our state and
deserve protection so I ask you to
please support a recommendation of ought
to pass on HB 105 and I'm welcome I
welcome any of your questions thank you
thank you representative rang any
questions from the committee
representative V thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
um why is C of bacteria such a health
concern what kind of conditions or what
what does it have on human oh thank you
representative for the question um
exposure to toxic
cyanobacteria is um has both acute and
chronic impacts on human health um acute
that mean would be exposure immediately
to a bloom would result in or may result
in skin rashes any ingestion would
result in gastrointestinal
distress um and headaches flu like
symptoms um chronically exposure to
certain toxins that are in
cyanobacteria and and I should say that
not all cyanobacteria are toxic but when
we identify a bloom um we assume that
there's toxicity in in the bloom and um
because there is severe tar there's um
anox sins which affect the liver and
there's neurotoxins which affect the the
neurological system there's very strong
evidence that's linking
exposure to a component of toxin called
bmaa to ALS and other neurological
diseases in fact there's a uh one of the
leading researchers in this field is Dr
Elijah STL out of Dartmouth um and his
research was has also been um supported
by research done at the University of
Miami so but it may take years there's
other elements um to contributing to
that ALS that besides could be
bmaa um but it is I mean I know people
personally who have had acute symptoms
of sinal bacteria blooms and they didn't
even know it was from Sino bacteria they
were just swimming from one side of a
lake to another and they didn't realize
they were swimming through a bloom and
then they got sick and the bloom was
identified and then they put two and two
together and there's also been pets who
have died and also pets who become very
very critically ill um from exposure
exposure to blooms and it's particularly
hazardous to the pets and children
because they have a a lower body mass
and so exposure to those
toxins have come at a much higher impact
larger but thank you for the question
any other questions from the committee
representative
Hill thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question representative
um difficult question to answer I'm I'm
certain but I wanted to see if you have
any any better information um you
mentioned the Moose plates that we
currently offer um my my suggestion
might be that some of the same people
buying the Moose plates would be buying
these so I'm not sure it's you would get
the accurate number of just by looking
at moose plates and and these and
thinking it would do the same but but at
$30 a piece which is what I'm gathering
here um
it would seem to me you'd have to sell
an enormous number of these to to to
make a dent in what is needed for um
Lake mitigation or or even um I I know
what the septic systems cost uh around
the lake and uh they're enormous so I'm
trying to figure out how this is going
to solve any kind of a large problem
that we have here thank you for the
question representative the $30 is based
on what the Moose plate is being charged
and um and I do expect that there may be
some people that switch from the Moose
plate to the loom plate I'll be one of
them but then there's other people like
my husband who doesn't have a special
plate and I know that he'll want to get
the Loon plate because he wants we've
been doing whatever we can personally to
support uh cyob bacteria mitigation um
Andrea larno who is the executive
director of New Hampshire Lakes I
believe they did a survey um of their
membership of who has moose plates that
would switch who doesn't have plates but
would get the Loon plat so she could
probably answer that part of your
question um and as far as the revenue of
this covering the costs of mitigation
projects it's not going to um but we do
receive uh 319 grants from the federal
government um other monies that can come
in um I look at the money coming in here
um and I don't want to speak for de yes
I know they're here but um it likely
would go to ensure that we do those
watershed management plans so we
identify where those sources of
nutrients going into a lake and that's
very important information because many
Lake Associations will fund their own
projects they'll do them but sometimes
just getting that upfront cost to do
that watershed management planning
because that takes about 18 months to
actually and that's a good timeline to
get one of those completed because
there's a lot of water testing that has
to go on there's a lot of inspection of
Shoreline to really understand non-point
Sol non-important sources of some of
these uh contaminants so it will help
and I don't want um I don't I forget is
it good to be the enemy of perfect I
think we need we need money to address
this problem and just because it's not
the money that will fund all of the
project s we have to do something it's
it I don't know if you're aware of last
summer but it was brutal up in the Lakes
Region with all the blooms they were
hitting lakes that never saw blooms
before follow up thank you Mr chairman
um I wonder if there is any and maybe
it's someone behind you that would have
the information about um how many
households would be affected um within a
with within New Hampshire just by um
effects in in various Lakes you know it
it would seem that um the density is
much greater around the lakes and and
I'm wondering how far away from that
concentric Circle theory of the of the
Lakes how many families would be
affected by um mitigation or something
like that is that part of those studies
yeah thank you um Dr Stalin Dartmouth um
has a
study and um he presented it to the sb85
commission uh a year ago almost a year
ago now um it was to health care
providers in New Hampshire it was a
presentation he gave to healthc care
providers but he shared it with the S
sp85 commission which looks at
environmentally triggered
diseases and I believe in that and it's
on YouTube if you want to look at it but
um I believe in that in among his slides
he showed that from three up to 3 to 5
kilometers away from a bloom um people
can inhale bmaa this was particularly
just looking at bmaa which is just a
component of certain cyanobacteria
blooms
so and he's also identified clusters of
ALS that have been associated with
chronic cyanobacteria blooms one um is
MOMA Lake and there's was one that was
identified I think a year or two ago
around the eastern shore of Lake
Champagne which has also been severely
impacted by blooms so it doesn't have to
be just people right next to the water
getting um skin contact with the toxins
the toxins can become um aized and
people can you know ingest them you know
can breathe them in and that can happen
3 to 5 kilometers away I don't know if
that answers your question
but there are there are um there's
studies going on all over the world
about this so the research is still is
still coming out but it is um not as
questionable as to what the impacts are
as they were five 10 years
ago and and I think that you know their
DS can probably answer that more but
those are the people that would pay more
for a license plate because they are
more direct IR ly impacted somebody who
is not doesn't go to the Lakes doesn't
contribute to the lake economy they're
not going to be forced to put into this
fund if unless they want to unless they
want to get that plate and pay the extra
$30 but $30 adds up when you look at um
I
think I had some data but there are
thousands and thousands of plates those
moose plates that are issued every year
I think it's it might be close to 2,000
I think it's over a th000 though for
sure
you representative
Crawford thank you um representative R
do you have any written testimony that
you want to yes I will share it with you
thank
you any other questions from the
much chair would now like to recognize
representative paternal who is in
support of the bill asking for one 1 to
two minutes welcome representative to
Transportation good morning thank you Mr
chair and the um committee for hearing
my testimony I just wanted to um I'm for
the record I'm Katie Pell I represent
the towns of wolfboro and tufton in the
beautiful Lakes Region and I just want
to express my support for this bill
especially it being a non-
taxpayer funded voluntary option to
raise awareness about the issue of cyano
bacteria and how it impacts our Lakes um
the two towns that I represent would be
are significantly impacted by these
cyanobacteria blooms they impact our
tourism and even our the health of our
local population taking advantage of the
Lakes so I just want to again just want
to express my support I don't have any
technical background or information to
add so you can ask me all the questions
you want and I probably won't be able to
answer them but thank you very much
thank representative any questions from
the
committee not seeing any thank you
Cher I would like to recognize
representative uh MC mcdom
McDonald uh who is in support of the
bill who is asking for two minutes
Transportation thank you Mr chairman I
appreciate the opportunity to speak to
you today I'm probably going to repeat a
lot of stuff that uh the previous
representative just said uh but I'm uh
repr K district 6 which is the community
of of w and tuoro and we'd like to ask
you to support this particular bill it's
an important bill as it deals with the
health of several hundred bodies of our
Waters in New Hampshire currently many l
many lakes and ponds are experiencing C
bacteria blooms these blooms affect not
only the health of the person in the
water or using the water but also the
economy in general I'm sure during the
summertime you may watch channel n and
they'll have cob bacterial warnings or
you'll see something on Facebook that
all has a negative effect on U uh
boating uh hotel rentals and generally
people come up coming up here to enjoy
our Waters uh would ask that you support
the 30 uh $30 fee which will establish
the cob bacteria mitigation loan and
Grant fund to address this growing
problem thank you thank you
representative any questions from the
committee not seey thank you so much
chery and i' like to recognize
Amy smuga did I get it right that was
pretty pretty good for was smula yep
smula from the New Hampshire Dees who is
asking for two minutes who has some
written testimony I believe you emails
yes correct yes it came over this
morning so my name is Amy smula I am
with the Department of Environmental
Services and I'm the director of the
limnology center there where we study
the water quality of lakes ponds and
rivers representative rung gave you a
really good background of the uh program
for Sino bacteria and the impacts and
I'd just like to build on that a little
bit from the the agency's
standpoint the Department of
Environmental Services is just tracking
this bill at this point we're remaining
neutral on the bill but I do want to
provide some uh information about the
blooms that we are seeing cyanobacteria
were for formerly called Blu green algae
that may have been another term that
were familiar with uh cyanobacteria is
the the current term that we are using
and they're often responsible for
producing harmful Alo blooms in surface
waters due to warm temperatures and high
nutrient concentrations they can also be
there when the nutrients are not high as
well in the past two years NH uh nhdes
has seen unprecedented numbers of
cyanobacteria blooms across our state
we've issued more than 120 cyanobacteria
warnings due to high cell counts we use
70,000 Mill 70,000 cells per milliliter
as a threshold and that's a fairly High
cell count that's usually when you see
the scummy growth along the shoreline
and it turns the water a bluish green
color uh and when it's that high they
can produce toxins which representative
rung nicely
reviewed so those cyanotoxins have been
documented to cause harm to Aquatic Life
and to human health so those are the
reasons why we're concerned it's more
than just the unsafe appearance of the
blooms in 2022 Governor cunu signed
House Bill 1066 into law which directed
the Department of Environmental Services
to develop a plan to prevent the
increase of and eventually control C of
bacteria blooms in the state water
bodies so after Governor cuno signed
that bill there was a commission that
worked for over a year to evaluate
different program elements that Dees
would Implement in the future to
mitigate the impacts of cyanobacteria
that effort is largely unfunded except
for a onetime $1 million appropriation
from the legislature that started off
the cyanobacteria mitigation fund and we
also did receive
$500,000 of as a onetime appropriation
from the American Rescue plan act
funding so we were working off about a
$1.5 million budget of that we only have
about
$200,000 left and that only funded a
hand full of projects around the state
to mitigate blooms we did some work on
lake
kakka and we have a project plan on
Partridge Lake in Littleton this spring
and then Tucker pond in Solsbury and
Province Lake in Effingham the list is
long and I actually of a a print out of
a spreadsheet of a number of blooms that
we have and we have dozens of water
bodies that are impacted by CYO bacteria
so the funding is limited so
establishing a a license plate program
would at least provide some degree of
dedicated funding to this program it may
not amount to large amounts annually but
it would be some degree of funding that
would keep this program going so that we
can help Leakes do studies or
implementation work to help uh reduce
the impacts of the
blooms uh so unfortunately that funding
is probably going to be used up in the
next couple of months as we have
projects coming in having a a program
like this would help protect our
freshwater resources which are used for
drinking water supplies which are used
for recreation for businesses so that
that would help a long way so with that
I'm happy to take any questions um I do
want to as I'm part of testimony address
uh representative Hill's question for
the number of households that could be
impacted from cyanobacteria blooms it's
a really hard number to predict for
example a lake like Partridge Lake which
is tucked away in Littleton probably has
40 homes on it so 40 families there
could be affected but if you look at the
example of lake kosaka and molteno which
probably has about 80 homes on it which
is about double that's that's more but
Lake kosaka flows into Center Harbor of
lake winaki so you're seeing the numbers
increase significantly there and the
lake kosaka Bloom was documented to flow
right into Blacky Cove of of lake winaki
so it became a second Lake problem so it
is sort of a Down The Chain F down the
chain follow the flow situation so it
time thank you so much any questions
from the committee
[Music]
representative CH thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um I'm
running a little late uh if you know um
what's the effect of Sino Bia on humans
on people so uh we do have a number of
documented impacts and it depends on the
cyanotoxin different cyanobacteria
produce different toxins some of the
toxins are
neurotoxins and some of them are liver
toxins some of them can cause dermatitis
some of them can cause
gastroenteritis so it it could be varied
um there have been documented cases in
other parts of the country where a
couple of boys that were swimming in a
golf course pond in a of bacteria Bloom
died because of their injuries they had
um liver necrosis as a result of that so
it it could be from mild to severe we
haven't had any documented significant
impacts in New Hampshire to human health
at this point but the possibility is
always there thank you so much
representative Hill thank you for taking
my question uh I appreciate it thank you
Mr chairman um and for the continued
response from the prior question um the
uh the handful of projects you mentioned
that you're currently um
undergoing are those studies or those
mitigation or Andor um what kind of
average expense are we talking about
sure so we've been trying to prioritize
the use of cyanobacteria mitigation
funds for implementation so actually
boots on the ground doing projects so
one of them Lake kosak
was already done and that was an inl
treatment it was an aluminum treatment
to when so when leaks have a lot of
phosphorus or nutrients coming up from
the lake bottom not only do you have all
the sources of nutrients coming in from
the land surrounding the lake the lake
is feeding from within so if we can
reduce the external inputs that aluminum
treatment will lock phosphorus into the
lak sediments to keep it from fueling
that bloom throughout the summer uh we
have another one of those planned at
part Lake in Littleton and then the
other projects Tucker Pond and Province
Lake were Watershed projects where we
had uh storm water and erosion and
sedimentation problems that are being uh
imple that are being implemented to
mitigate those
impacts because the money is so scarce
we're trying to very carefully
prioritize those projects and the
funding that we're giving is usually
already well vetted to be put to good
use so those water based studies are
already done and updated and ready to
go follow up thank you
um are the so I'm hearing from um from
you that it's not always a man-made um
instance that causes these blooms it can
be a natural um from the from the lake
bed is that what I hear unfortunately no
all those nutrients that build up in the
bottom of the lake are from typically
water shed uses Leakes are settling
basins they're the low point in the
landscape and they build up materials
over time so a lot of that did come
originally from The Watershed but when
you have it built up to a certain degree
in a lake and lakes lose oxygen at the
bottom there's a chemical reaction that
takes place so it antagonizes the the
bloom effect so it is ultimately human
driven to begin with but it just builds
up over time and exacerbates the problem
uh and I didn't answer another part of
your question you asked dollar values
the a couple of our projects have been
in the $ 250 to $500,000 range per leak
some of them are as small as 10 or
$15,000 so they're all over the board it
really just depends on what the
situation is it's not a one-size fitall
every water body has a a pathway forward
to remediation and it it has to it it's
just varied depending on the project
thank you any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much Cher and I like to recognize lizo
it says information only did you want to
speak a little bit or sure from the DMV
registration hi um I'm Liz mad I'm in
charge of the registration Bureau at the
division of motor vehicles and I really
just wanted to we're neutral on this
Phill um but I wanted to provide you
guys with how things may or may not
ffect our operations at the DMV by
issuing a new plate type um it's very
minimal so there's a minor system change
would be needed where we add a new plate
type in and then we would get a template
made um and send that over to the prison
um for production but again it would be
very similar to the Moose plates so the
financial impact would be very minimal
to the
dmbb thank you so much representative
representative Crawford
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I I saw that the fee
for making the plate uh well no for the
software was you estimated about
$25,000 so in the past being on this
committee for 12 years um we were always
given a a cost of like
$240,000 what's changed since then is it
just um better software better process
and software could you tell it's been
streamlined it's a lot easier to add a
new plate type now um it doesn't require
quite as many hours as it did um and
also uh since we've been doing this and
have some several specialty plates
already um adding a new one isn't quite
as
challenging any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much thank
you chairman now like to um recognize um
Andrea
LMO if I didn't butcher your name from
The New Hampshire Lake
who is in the support of the bill asking
minutes welcome to Transportation thank
you good morning I'm Andrea lamro
president and policy advocate of New
Hampshire lakes and we're here to uh um
speak in strong support of this bill uh
New Hampshire Lakes were a Statewide
nonprofit organization our mission is to
restore and preserve the health of our
Lakes you've heard the warning uh that
the health of our Lakes is degrading uh
causing serious public health concerns
um lowering property values um impacting
tourism um potential to impact local and
state
economies so um you have learned a lot
about Lake ecology this morning U my
colleagues uh did a great job um and we
support this bill for all of the reasons
um presented Before You and I just
wanted to take a few minutes to address
some of the questions and comments that
came have come up so far uh so New
Hampshire Lakes we have I've been um
informally surveying Lake Associations
for the past three Summers I go out
every every weekend to two or three Lake
Associations during the summer these
Community groups working around their
lakes and talk about you know would you
be interested in this type of plate um
and we you know have a show of hands and
we also recently did a Sur survey and
about 500 folks um responded to our
survey and I saw about a hundred folks
signed in online and supported this this
bill and our survey was you know one do
you have a moose plate um you know if
you do have a moose plate would you
switch to a lake plate if you don't have
a you know moose plate and you register
in New Hampshire would you buy a lake
plate to summarize our results uh we
found that about 1% of our respondents
said I have a moose plate and I would
switch um of of our survey population
about 25% said they had a moose plate
and they would keep the Moose plate but
then they would buy a lake plate for
their second car um and then about 75%
of our survey folks said they don't have
a moose plate they're not interested in
a moose plate but they would definitely
get a lake plate so I do feel that this
is going to be a very um popular uh
plate we have 1,000 Lakes uh people will
want to buy these first of all to
celebrate the Heritage the culture Our
Lake culture and our heritage here
people are proud of that it can also
serve as awareness that um our Lakes are
fragile and and need to be protected and
we can do a whole Outreach campaign
about that um and most importantly it
would bring in funds to help um the the
fund the S bacteria mitigation loan and
Grant fund providing loans and grants to
community groups to do do the work to
improve these Lakes for the benefit of
all there is not enough money currently
this is not going to solve that deficit
but it's going to help and we've got to
start somewhere so thank you very much
uh for this opportunity and I I have
testimony that I passed around I also
passed testimony around for the Lakes
management advisory committee who is
also supporting this bill I'm happy to
answer any questions thank you so much
any questions from the
committee representative Hill thank you
um this is a subject that's near and
dear to my heart I think um is um I
haven't heard um Landscaping mentioned
in this entire talk um and I haven't
heard whether that is um is instrumental
or or part of the problem um with any of
the uh uh Landscaping that goes on
around around the legs is that something
that your organization is concerned
about or um spreading any information
when you meet with the group about
absolutely that's a great question yes
how we care for the landscape around the
lake um can protect the lake or
potentially harm it so you know um we
may do things that cause polluted runoff
water to come into the lake bringing in
fertilizer or something like that so yes
uh we run a Statewide program called the
lak smart program it's a lak friendly
Living Program and over the past uh four
or five years we've worked with over a
thousand folks throughout the state
helping them adopt Lake friendly ways of
managing their property around the lake
so absolutely that is that is a concern
um how people care for their properties
and and we're here to help people adopt
ways to landscape their property in a
lak friendly
way you're welcome any other questions
from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much thank you that is all the pink
cards I have so at this point I'd like
to end the testimony on HB 105 our next
fill up would be HB 140 uh just give us
up
all
right gonna open up the hearing on HB HB
140 establishing a voluntary blue
envelope program for drivers with autism
spectrum disorders and the chair I'd
like to recognize representative Newell
representative welcome to Transportation
thank you thank you Mr chair and thank
you to the members of the committee for
your time and consideration today I'm
jod n and I represent chesher 4 in
Keem so this bill aims to formalize a
system which would Aid in communication
between members of law enforcement and
drivers with autism spectrum disorders
fortunately for us we already have clear
guidance on who may qualify and even a
comparable program to Aid in
communication for folks who are deaf or
hard of hearing granted that program is
customized to fit the needs of that
Community the blue envelope program has
been successfully implemented elsewhere
including many of our neighbor states
with essentially the same structure
making it an increasingly
recognizable uh and therefore commonly
understood practice it is a voluntary
program and the amount of information
provided is up to the participant the
design elements uh it being in an
envelope easy to access um uh
connectable to the visor um make it for
easy and visible
access by all accounts this is a low
lift for the state that can make a world
of difference for folks in our community
who may struggle with communication in
potentially stressful moments as I
understand it there have been
conversations around adopting the blue
envelope program for some time my goal
in introducing this legislation is
simply uh to underscore our support of
immediate action to that effect and uh
to demonstrate our resolve to a uh as a
body uh to support those community
members who B who will benefit from the
program's implementation thank you very
much I'm happy to take any questions
thank you so much any questions from
committee representative
gon thank you Mr chair uh you mentioned
several other states uh surrounding that
use this program could you tell us what
states those are please yeah I know that
Massachusetts and Connecticut have uh
Connecticut I think is the most recent
one as of last year um and I believe
Maine has as well I think
Vermont sorry I Yes actually I'm sorry
yes Vermont yes Connecticut in
Massachusetts and I'm pretty sure about
main although I'm not 100% sure it's
yet representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman um thank you for taking my
question um are you aware that uh just
last week I think it is when we did our
orientation meeting uh the director of
uh DMV mentioned to us that they would
be doing this program internally um
without the legislation
yes I I not particularly that uh that it
was brought up in your orientation um
but I do know that it's been a
conversation for some time I think um
what I tried to really get at here is us
as a body uh passing legislation to that
effect I don't think that either one
cancels out each other uh I think that
both of these things work in Tandem and
if they get to it before uh our
legislation gets through that's great uh
I you know either way I think it's
wonderful but I don't think that that
legislation any other questions from the
committee representative Au thank you
thank you for taking my question um
would this just be limited to people
with Autism Spectrum Disorder or could
it be applied to uh broader disorders
that might actually have conflicts with
police on stops like this this
particular program is for folks with
autism spectrum disorders um you know
that doesn't rule out doing something in
the future that might uh be able to
cater to more people but this particular
purpose my my question is kind of
followup to representative values the
autism spectrum disorders can you give
us kind of a list of some of those
disorders well I think actually I could
refer that to some of the folks who are
giving testimony today uh to give a
little more um understanding I I
wouldn't want to um say anything out of
turn but I know that there are folks
here who can speak to that better than I
can okay thank you any other questions
from the committee not seeing any thank
you very much thank
you chair i' like to recognize
representative seig who is in support of
the bill asking for about two minutes
representative welcome to thank you so
much um for the record my name is
representative Lauren selig and I
represent the town of Durham in straford
county and I am in favor of this bill um
over the past several days I've been
rereading reading the bill to make sure
that I understood many of the nuances
because obviously with all of our
legislation there can be very specific
challenges I then um took the liberty of
speaking to a person who oversees police
departments um to get a sense of what
concerns might be raised as a result of
the bill and uh the person I spoke to
was initially very skeptical of the idea
of a blue envelope program imagining
police officers on the side of the road
trying to open an envelope and see all
kinds of things or people fumbling in a
glove compartment which could make a
police officer feel at risk um but upon
rereading the bill and clarifying the
fact that the envelopes would be on
their uh the visor the sun visor and
that the information would be on the
outside and an easily located thing um
those are things that indicate ways to
support communication with police and
support the process which could actually
make police officers safer in traffic
stops um extrapolating from that I also
think about the situation where we all
know that if we have are in a car
accident whether it's a fender bender or
more serious incident our adrenaline
goes up our you know whole body system
has a reaction to that if we're a person
on the autism spectrum disorder we may
not know how to manage all of those
feelings and if someone who is another
type of first responder whether a
firefighter or an ambulance comes and
they've looked on the visor and see oh
this person has autism spectrum disorder
let me and it says that you know these
three words can help calm them down it
can make that situation much less
dangerous and much safer for everybody
involved um it's also the responsibility
of the vehicle operator to provide the
information it's not on the police
department and there's no um liability
to the police if they haven't seen it
you know it's not adding a burden it's
ultimately um working in a way to assist
police and support them in supporting
people in this situation so for all of
these reasons and because I know a lot
of people who are the Spectrum I really
support this
legislation thank you so much any any U
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much thank you so
much chair and now like to recognize
representative wheeler who is in support
of the bill asking for one minute quite
suin there representative welcome to
Transportation thank you chairman Gorski
members of the transportation committee
always good to see some friendly faces
here and congratulations on your
appointment chair I know you'll do a
good job here with your leadership train
just for the day representative W know
thinking so I'm just here really quickly
to affirm my support as I said I only
need a minute because there are people
here who can speak
more aptly to what this legislation does
and and why it's important to have the
legislation but I think I affirm the
support of Liz Sergeant here at the
association of Chiefs of police who
signed in support of this and and the
common sense approach to just making
sure that the police are safer and that
communication between those who can't
communicate as easily but can still
drive and between them and the police is
is as as uh easy can be to avoid any any
potential problems because the police
don't want issues and and they're very
supportive of this kind of program to
make sure that they have that level of
communication before the stop to for
their own safety but for the safety of
the people in the car as well and and I
think for the people in the car it's a
common sense safe approach for for what
we can do here
today happy to take any questions but I
do also have to get to committee so any
questions from the committee not seeing
any thank you
representative chair now like to
recognize representative
Howard who is in support of the bill
asking for two minutes welcome the
transportation representative thank you
Mr chair and uh honorable members I I
probably shouldn't uh even need two
minutes but uh my name is representative
Heath Howard I serve the towns of
straford and barington in straford
District 4 and I think that we should be
establishing a voluntary blue envelope
program because it is common sense that
we should help improve communication
between law enforcement in any way we
can while the DMV is in the process of
creating this program it has taken over
two years without an end date in sight
this would create a timeline for the
program to be implemented by the start
of next year and should be more than
enough time for the DMV to
comply I think that uh we can all agree
that three years should be enough time
to implement a program like this and I
hope that you agree uh thank you and I'm
open to any
questions thank you so much any
questions from the
committee representative
Json yes I see that you're a co-sponsor
on this I'm wondering if um if the
sponsors would entertain a amendment to
include
pts uh PTSD yeah I would be I'd be open
to
that any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much thank
you chair now like to recognize Jennifer
Smith who's representing herself who's
asking for two minutes who is opposing
the
bill well never
mind which is my my apologies wrong one
all right uh chair I like to recognize
Luis
espito who has some written
testimony not sure if you're support or
bill asking for two to three
Transportation uh honorable chair and
committee members uh thank you for the
opportunity to speak to you all here
today uh for the record my name is Lewis
Esposito and I am the executive director
of able New Hampshire and I'm also a
former special education teacher um able
New Hampshire is a disability Justice
organization and a nonpartisan nonprofit
entity that fights for the civil and
human rights of children and adults with
disability I'm here today to provide
testimony to discuss the benefits of the
blue envelope program this program is an
essential step toward um improving
safety reducing misunder understanding
and promoting inclusion for individuals
with disabilities within their
communities bless you um interactions
between law enforcement and individuals
with autism disorders of special
disorders can often be challenging due
to differences in communication Styles
sensory sensitivities and behavioral
responses Research indicates that people
with Autism inspection disorders are at
heightened risk of negative outcomes
during police interactions due to
misunderstandings of their behaviors uh
for example uh communication barriers
many individuals with ASD struggle with
verbal communication which can lead to
delayed or atypical responses during
high stress situations such as traffic
stops officers May misinterpret these
behaviors as non-compliance or Defiance
increasing the likelihood of escalation
um behavioral misinterpretation uh
common autistic behaviors such as
stemming or avoiding eye contact are
often misunderstood by law enforcement
as signs of nervousness or aggression
one study found that 60% of caregivers
of individuals with autism feared police
contact due to concerns about
misinterpretations um barriers to
inclusion um these inter interactions
can reinforce systematic barriers
preventing individuals with ASD from
feeling safe and included in their
communities negative experiences with
law enforcement can discourage
individuals from driving or engaging in
community activities that Foster
Independence and social connections the
blue envelope program addresses these
challenges by providing a structured
straightforward way to communicate
essential information research
highlights the importance of tools and
training to improve interactions between
law enforcement and individuals with
disability um there's a precedent for
Success similar programs implemented in
other states have shown promise reducing
misunderstandings oring traffic stops um
it's also an inclusion focused outcome
um tools like the blue envelope program
Empower individuals with disabilities to
participate more fully in their
Community by removing one of the key
barriers to Independent mobility and
Community engagement um the blue
envelope program offers offers several
key benefits um safety for drivers and
officers by providing law enforcement
with information on the driver's
communication needs the program reduces
the likelihood of escalation and fosters
a safer environment for all parties
involved um empowerment and inclusion um
individuals with ASD and the families
gain confidence knowing that they have a
tool to facilitate smoother interactions
with law enforcement um it has a proven
Effectiveness um studies suggest that
drivers with ASD experience a sta uh
statistically significant reduction in
anxiety and improved preparedness
following exposure to tools like the
blue envelope program and cost effective
with an estimated fiscal impact of less
than $10,000 annually the program
benefits far away its modest cost um a
blue envelope program underscores the
importance of removing uh barriers and
fostering equity um disability is not
merely a medical issue but a social one
shaped by the environment and policies
that either um enable or inhibit um
inclusion um the blue envelope program
represents a proactive solution to a
significant issue by fostering better
communication understanding and
inclusion we can protect individuals
with autism while ensuring law
enforcement officers have the tools they
need to perform their duties effectively
thank you I can answer any questions
that you m might have any questions from
the
committee representative a thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question can you describe some of the
situations that have happened in the
past that give rise to the to the need
for this anecdotally when I was a
special education teacher prior to this
there were a lot of
um a lot of stress and anxiety for
students that were going through the
driver ed program and not just from the
students but from their families um by
you know like poor eye contact or just
nervousness in situations that you might
not have an everyday experience with a
lot of people with Autism need a lot of
repetition and understanding and this is
not something get a lot of practice with
um I don't have a lot of um testimony
from people that have gone through this
but I do know I've heard anecdotally
from people that do get nervous during
it actually actually actually have a
question that I asked earlier is there a
list of the spectrum disorders that this
falls under it's just autism just autism
um yeah autism spectrum disorders is a
wide range uh there's level one level
two and level three um level one
previously um in previous dsms where was
more um commonly um called um Asbergers
but they have recently um well about a
decade or so ago removed that so now
it's just autism inspection disorders
but everyone experiences autism
differently so it's really hard to um
have a uh Universal you know perceptive
perspection on what autism actually is
from person to
person thank you any other questions
representative Fox thank you Mr chair um
just to clarify um
um um Asbergers does not fall
Aspergers is no longer a common
definition of autism Aspergers has been
so the diagnostic statistics manual four
had Aspergers in it as a diagnosis
criteria for autism however the dsm5 no
longer categorizes um Aspergers they
don't um diagnose it anymore now it is
um more commonly occur of called um
autism level one um but it's it's it's
very diverse
group follow up so it would fall into
the category the blue envelope cat yeah
if somebody had a previous diagnosis of
autism I would assume that they would um
fall under that category thank you any
other questions from the committee not
seeing any thank you so much thank you
all chair now i' like to recognize uh
director morasco from the DMV who says
this is
informational director welcome to
Transportation good morning Mr chair
members of the committee thank you so
much for the opportunity to address you
uh my name is John morasco director of
the DMV um I just wanted to to say and
I'll be brief uh I did have a
conversation with representative hill
within the last few months uh and he
brought to my attention for the first
time the blue envelope program um sounds
like a wonderful program sounds like
something that would really help people
uh it's opt in and so I I heard the
testimony about several years in the
process I just want to on the record say
that this is the first time when the
representative brought it to me that
during my tenure at the DMV I've had the
opportunity to look at it uh we have
been making uh strides to um to move
forward with this to include I as I
testified to uh during our orientation
had the opportunity to speak with
director John Skipper at the New
Hampshire police St and Training Academy
he thinks it's a wonderful idea there
would be a law enforcement training
component he's happy to work with us to
uh to get there uh when we get to that
point I've also spoken with uh office of
Highway Safety program manager John CLE
about uh the cost that would be
associated with production of the blue
envelopes and uh John was going to look
into that and uh as I testified to I
don't think the cost is going to be
overwhelming so even if we can't receive
some federal money to support it um for
the uh for the voluntary program I'm
sure that we could print some of these
out through our budget so um I also
would be interested if the bill passes
to work with the sponsor and others who
have testified here this morning um to
roll it out uh and also to make sure
that we have the proper information on
the exterior of the uh the envelope
itself I know other states are using it
but I just want to make sure medically
uh we're providing the exact information
that we should be that's it's going to
help law enforcement and others when
they receive the envelope so um I think
we need to formalize the process whether
the bill passes or not we're still uh to
the representative's point we're going
to keep working towards it and um we're
going to make it a priority so just
wanted to put that on the record and
happy to take any questions thank you
sir any questions from the committee
representative foot thank you Mr chair
thank you director so is this a a
voluntary thing or something that would
need uh proper documentation from a
physician or something like that to to
get into this program yeah that's that's
one area I would like to look at um how
how one would um would would get you
know the envelope but I I think um we
would have to have a conversation on
that to see how that would work I
mean hopefully people that uh would be
taking the envelope would actually need
it um and would be using it for for the
purposes that it should be used for but
I want to have a larger conversation on
that part of it thank you any other
questions from the committee
representative a thank you for taking my
question um what concerns do you have
about privacy and training and maybe the
administrative aspects of this
program excellent question
representative um I haven't thoroughly
looked at it from that perspective um I
I guess based on my understanding of the
program and we had um our our admin
three administrator 3 Ashley gray uh
prepare a beautiful memo on an overview
of the program um my understanding based
on what I read There is that um there's
some bullets on the outside of the
envelope that just gives some basic
information that you could be dealing
somebody with somebody um that is uh has
autism um and these are some best
practices that you can quickly Implement
to improve the communication uh my
understanding is that the information
that would be you know whether it's a
driver's license registration any other
documentation would be inside the
envelope um so I don't see it being
disclosed or available that way um so I
don't know that there's any personal
information on the exterior of the
envelope but I'd have to look into that
I I I will follow up that's a good
question okay any other questions from
the committee representative
Sykes thank you Mr chairman
director that memo that you referred to
earlier is that something that you can
make available to the committee so we
can follow the discussion absolutely y
it's an overview of the program and um
as well as what it would take to get it
off the ground absolutely thank you
you're welcome sir any other questions
from the committee not seeing thank you
sir thank you Mr chair thank okay with
that I have nobody else uh listed for
Testimony so at this point I'm going to
close the hearing on HB 140 our next one
coming up is HB 182 just need a few
your
know
all right being uh 11:02 we like to
start the public hearing on HB
182 prohibiting electric vehicles in
commercial parking garages chair like to
recognize representative uh Steve
Pearson who will be introducing the bill
are we good there we are there we are
all right good morning colleagues um the
reason I'm sitting before you
introducing this bill real quick is
because representative PR is having a
transportation problem broken down on
the side of the highway right now so for
the record I'm Representative Steve
Pearson rocking Camp District 13 I'm in
my fourth term representing
Derry and uh I'm doing representative
Pro a solid hair
so what you have before you is should be
familiar this is virtually identical
language to the bill that was introduced
ago fortunately I I can speak to the
technical aspect of this I've been in
the fire service for 27 years I have an
engineering degree in the practice from
Oklahoma State University as well as a
master's degree in Emergency Management
so I can speak to a little bit of the
from a solely engineering standpoint why
this
matters electric vehicles due to the
nature in which they are constructed do
a couple of
things and two of the big things and the
reason why this bill needs to to exist
is because a burning electric vehicle
produces a tremendous amount of toxic
smoke this is not toxic smoke that you
will cough out this is is not toxic
smoke that you will take in a large
quantity of it's actually quite small
it's so small that similar type
batteries in
scooters can kill you if you live in an
apartment so that's the first aspect of
this the second one is the the necessary
resources that have to respond to put
one of these out that's on
fire a normal carire I've done hundreds
of them in my career
will require a tank load of water at
best these
vehicles to equate it will require 44
engine companies worth of water to put
out
so if you do not have a robust Municipal
Water System if you do not have a plan
in place to extinguish these you are
firefight the sprinkler
systems that exist in some parking
garages that are up right now were never
designed for this type of fire
load
now this leaves you with a couple of
options one you can engage in a
substantial firefight it's very risky
it's very drawn out it's extraordinarily
labor intensive the other option you
have is you can hook a vehicle to the
electric vehicle that's on fire and try
to drag it
out now that option which has been used
to my knowledge once that I can
confirm requires a firefighter to crawl
under the car to hook it while it's on
fire um which I don't necessarily
recommend the other thing is to drag a
burning electric vehicle out of a
parking garage require Ires a truck that
will fit in the parking garage in order
to remove it so generally speaking that
is considered not really an
option there are some technological
advancements if you will there is a
company that sells a cover that you will
throw over the electric car with the
idea of putting it
out um those don't really work they do
not do anything to change the chemical
process the battery burning and they
certainly do not provide any cooling
vehicle okay so what ultimately why do
we care well the heat generated from a
burning electric vehicle will compromise
concrete so we're looking at situations
where we could potential aside the fact
that the vehicles next to the electric
vehicle will catch fire from this we're
looking at structural concerns of the
parking garage
that is the importance of this issue so
important in fact that New York City has
already dealt with it you can't do it in
New York
City so they've recognized already the
problem with the electrical Vehicles
burning now keep in mind let's say that
we do get the electric vehicle out of
the parking garage
successfully salvage yards want nothing
to do with them the tow truck guys don't
like them if they're
burning and we have salvage yards now
that have created in that's in swimming
pools so when these electric vehicles
show up they dip they Park them for a
month they have to sit for a month in a
swimming pool in essence in order to
ensure that the fire is out it takes a
month so looking at the overall
situation what is risk risk is
probability times
severity and I've heard arguments well
you know there's been few fires limited
fires sure sure but the severity of a
fire of an electrical vehicle in a
substantial I think this issue needs to
be addressed it's not it's been assigned
some sort of a little bit of a partisan
um context to it it's not this is just
science this is just dealing with the
realities of an electric vehicle
so I I support this idea I certainly uh
ask for your consideration on it and I'm
welcome to uh questions if you have any
thank you representative any questions
from the committee representative Coker
thank you Mr chair so my understanding
is the reason it takes so much water is
because you're really not putting out
the fire you're literally having to wait
energy there are two there are two
concerns with that one is access right
because the majority of electric
vehicles if I could flip on over yeah
that'd be great right but I can't really
do that yeah and I certainly can't do
that in the confines of a parking garage
so um there you know you
are you are trying to interfere with a
chemical chain reaction and you're
trying to do it with something that
really isn't designed to do that so the
idea the the quantity of water is
necessary to cool things down to hope
that the Chain Reaction
slows in order for us to get the vehicle
out right that that's that's the only
method we have so um
and that's why they have to dip them
that's why the wrecking yards have to to
isolate them and dip them in a pool for
a month yeah because that's really the
only option they have so like literally
I mean and that's the the point is like
lit oh sorry follow up you're you're
literally having to um just let them
burn themselves out you really it's very
almost impossible to interrupt that
chemical
reaction yep you are
correct representative
Jason thank you Mr chair so am I correct
in interpreting this as all parking
garages in the state of New Hampshire
not municipal or state-owned but all
parking garages in the state of
Hampshire I don't have a copy of it in
front of me so I'll have to
remember but the language is the
language is in front of
you follow up we have several major
Employers in the state of New Hampshire
who've invested in charging stations in
their employees parking garages and and
encourage their employees to charge
there is there
any thing that we are going to do to
lessen the impact on the companies that
have paid for this service for their
employees on their private property in
their private garages sure those private
companies on private property carry
insurance I bet and when the Risk
Managers and the inspectors which an
industry that I was in prior to being in
the fire service in New Hampshire come
and inspect those facilities the dollar
will tell them what to do with that if
if this legislature does not because the
the risk associated with the fire and
the loss associated with that garage and
other things the insurance companies
have a vested interest in having an
opinion
on representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question representative um my
understanding from the previous time
this bill came before us we had a
discussion as well uh with
representative PR about um the toxicity
of the of the water that is used within
the garage and how that can um find its
way to water sources uh drinking water
sources nearby um that was one issue
that was brought up and I wonder if you
could speak on that the other issue um U
that was brought up a couple of times
here was the weight and I'm wondering if
there's been any um changes in building
codes for new construction um and and
how those
judg to Prior building codes do you know
okay so as far as your three-part
question the the first part with the
toxicity um all burning vehicles that we
put out unfortunately the water runoff
does contain all kinds of stuff um in an
electric vehicle situation the car
itself is really generally no different
than any other car it's just a fuel cell
um and it would depend if the fuel cell
ruptured or not ultimately as far as
that element of it
entertaining wherever the water goes
we're not going to wa we are not going
to focus on water runoff in these
situations we don't have the Manpower
we're struggling to find water and we're
trying to figure out how to keep our
people safe the runoff of that is at
least of our worries but after the fact
it will have to be dealt with no doubt
but it's going to depend if the fuel
cell ruptures are not as to the severity
of that um you mentioned weight I'll
give you an example of weight a an
electric Hummer
the battery pack alone weighs more than
a Honda Civic just the batteries that
doesn't include the whole vehicle so it
is there is no doubt that the weight
issue is not has not been factored into
the construction of existing garages now
as far as code changes go I'm not sure I
sit on Edna we're looking at the next
update of codes that are going to be
brought in and I'm not sure what has
changed as far as the structural um
requirements within a parking garage if
it's been addressed or
not but it will it will certainly need
hasn't quick follow up follow up um
should have should have asked this in my
list of questions but um aside from
parking garages um as with your
professional experience would there be a
need as we do I believe with things like
uh gas stations and and fireworks stores
not putting them next to schools or or
assisted living facilities or any of
that is there would there be any need
for any of that not really as far if
they're outside no no it's it's just
another Hazard it's just another thing
that we deal with in the fire service um
if I have a burning electric vehicle
that's
outdoors I have a couple of better
options I don't I'm not in confined
space it's a lot easier to operate um
again they're ultimately if you do have
to drag it away it is extraordinarily
somebody at the vehicle to hook a chain
to it but um you know I have a sticker
inside my helmet that says firefighting
is an ultra hazardous profession we're
not disillusioned to that so I I don't I
don't see that as a as something that's
over the top when it comes to just
proximity of things this is really about
confining an electric vehicle in a
struct
that is not designed to handle what is
about to come from it that that's really
what it's about so um you know that as
far as proximities to schools and
there's there's that's not really
necessary any other questions from the
committee representative Coker thank you
Mr chairman U charging increases the
risk of a fire
correct active charging sure I mean you
have um I mean that that holds true with
with this that holds true with my
Milwaukee battery pack for my tools yeah
anytime that you a lithium ion battery
is charged there is potential so you
know
it's this is not a matter of okay well
if we don't charge in parking garages
we'll I think we'll be fine that's
that's not really the issue here because
these vehicles have have burned and
caught fire when they were not in the
mode of charging thank
you representative
sites thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative to take my question um so
as far as you am I correct in
understanding that as far as you know uh
the National Fire Protection Association
has not adopted any changes relative to
garages well it's funny you mentioned
the nfpi I worked as a technical adviser
for that organization and spent 15 years
as a certified fire protection
specialist from the NFPA um I why I'm
asking the question it has been a long
time since I worked for them um I know
that electric vehicles have been
addressed by the NFPA as a as a special
hazard class that's something that is
ongoing with that process within the
fire codes um as to exactly what the
NFPA has done within the code I'm not
entirely sure but I do know this the
state of New Hampshire has not adopted
that nfba standard so there therefore
has no effect in no rule of law
here representative foot thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
taking my question sure uh as far as
these fires with these electric vehicles
do they have any causation that we know
of what what causes them to catch on
fire like with a regular gas powered
vehicle a lot of times could be like a
oil leak or whatnot so with the EVS how
does that sure I mean you
generally
speaking it's a it's a it's the Chain
Reaction within the battery that goes a
muck right that that's the
oversimplification of the answer to that
right so as far as like the way the
investigators work EVS it's tough
because you have to look at the look at
the EV after it's out so it's going to
sit in a pool for a month right and then
what are we looking at here so generally
they're not D they're not dissecting
electric vehicles my fire investigators
don't do that in the city it's a that's
the cause we know what the cause is it's
the electric vehicle caught fire now are
there Specialists that exist that look
at those there probably are I don't know
of it I don't know any personally but um
I would think the manufacturers would be
have a vested interest underwriter's
laboratory Tesla those folks would have
a vested interest in looking at
causation but um as far as you know at a
municipal level that that's not that's
not something we really have in New
Hampshire representative sites thank you
again Mr chairman thank you
representative sure
um are you I guess I'm trying to I'm
struggling with the
um the the numbers of actual electrical
vehicle fires in parking garages that we
have as it as uh raw numbers I
mean is it not fair to say
that um we try to look at risk as the
likelihood that something happens and
the frequency that it does happen will
change the way we look at the risk isn't
that isn't that how both the NFPA and
insurance companies and actually
firefighters fire uh making decisions on
the fire ground is that not the basis
under which they make decisions yeah
like I said probability times severity
right so yes the we don't have electric
vehicles burning up in New Hampshire
every day that that's just not happening
but the problem is we also don't have
nuclear power plants melting down in New
Hampshire every day either but we have a
substantial substantial amount of safety
that goes into seabook right because the
probability is extraordinarily low but
the severity is fairly substantial and
that's the same situation with these in
a parking
garage we could go 10 years without one
but the first time we have one and it's
on the first floor and we drop a parking
garage then we're looking at we're
looking at some serious issues we're
looking at some serious concerns again
for the heal the welfare and the safety
of our firefighters so that that's just
risk any other questions from the
representative chair now recognizes
Jennifer Smith
who's representing herself who opposes
the bill who is asking for 2 minutes
welcome to Transportation I got it right
this
time okay thank you
um Mr chair and and members of the
committee um I I think this topic will
require a lot of exploration and um I I
want to First just say I've been driving
eeve for over 10 years and because the
early batteries were pretty small um it
it was impossible to get to things in
Hanover and Portsmouth both places I
wanted to go in fact I was studying
Public Health um at uh Dartmouth at the
time that I first bought an electric
vehicle um and the presence of chargers
in parking garages is kind of essential
then and if you're going further and
want to be there for a while it's rather
important too
um outdoor Chargers are fine that's
that's okay but there are Chargers in
first floor in Portsmouth there are
Chargers in first floor in handle now
those are cities they're
Municipal
um there is at darmouth Hitchcock
Medical Center a series of chargers that
are on an upper floor I don't know
whether that's considered really safer
it would take a whole lot longer for
Fire Equipment
to and quick research I don't find much
about parking garage fires and I don't
think the charging is much of an issue I
think the um people who do the charging
and I've charged in many places across
the Northeast um are pretty careful as
are the manufacturers to be better about
the safety of all of
that and the only thing I've seen is
actually um from seal Korea um there was
a vehicle in a parking garage not
charging that caught fire and caused
extensive damage so there are a lot of
EVS in the world
um Norway is on track for
80% uh new car sales being electric
because they have such good electric
sources and it's so much more
environmentally and economically
responsible for them and probably within
a couple of years 100% of their new
vehicles will be electric not heard much
in the way of issues I think you know
yes there have been issues so that's I
think speaks to
frequency um I I hope you will look at
this carefully and yeah there are
some solutions I
think but I have been following this
issue of electric vehicle fires since it
was raised to me a few years ago in a
town meeting considering whether we
might get electric vehicles for um
certain Town uses we actually have a
electric tra truck going in clearly that
will be outdoors but that is a huge
battery um and I wouldn't point out that
a Hummer uh would also have a huge
amount of
gasoline or diesel I don't know if they
do diesel Hummers um that could
compromise a parking garage too I I
think these things are becoming less
frequent as safety measures have been
put in um I have not yet heard of a
burning electric vehicle in New
Hampshire but we don't have as many but
there are many places that do have lots
of electric vehicles and by the way I
have charged inside parking structures
in New York City it is now actually a
law in New York to mandate that parking
structures put in EV charging level two
charging occurs pretty slowly but that's
the ideal place is when you're
parking level three charging when you're
traveling across the country might be
more risky but I have not heard of fires
at a level three any place I've been um
and probably there have been somewhere
the two fires in New York City from
charging uh
electric bikes were
devastating but they were due to
improper equipment not matched to the
batteries um and they were not the toxic
smoke which is real um but it was
actually the building things catching on
fire from people doing
that so I I think you know you need to
study this a lot more carefully before
doing that and speak to those who have
Chargers dmouth
Hitchcock in Lebanon um the Handover
garage which you know they charge so is
that commercial I don't know it's
Municipal but it is commercial in the
sense that they charge and Portsmouth
which has two garages with electric
charges within them
um so I think you need to think
carefully about that and um I would hope
you don't pass this
bill any questions from the
much chair now like to recognize Chris
skand from clean energy New
Hampshire who is asking for three
minutes who is opposing the bill welcome
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Chris scogland I'm
the director of energy transition with
clean energy New Hampshire uh we're
often thought of as a treat group but we
represent uh a membership that includes
up to 40 municipalities representing
about a third of the state's population
all three of the states electrical
utilities and Natural Gas Utilities as
well as
uh many businesses residents and other
nonprofit organizations that are
partnering with us to ensure that as
technology advances we're adopting the
most advantageous policies for our
economy we do oppose this bill um in
part because the evidence does not
suggest that EVS pose as high a risk
it's a low probability there may be
risks that are associated with it but uh
more recent studies suggest that
internal combustion engines otherwise
referred to as ice vehicles uh burn
between 25 and 29 times more frequently
so it's a it's a significant a larger
part of the fires that we see um this is
repeated in the US but then in countries
where we have adoption of EVS up to 90%
such as Norway
um they are likewise seeing very low uh
fires uh we're concerned that this uh
issue um is we're picking a solution
without quite studying it yet and uh I
believe it was Senate bille 431 last
session created the lithium battery fire
Council um which enshrined a group that
had been convened by the fire marshall
Shan Tumi and several uh state agencies
and fire departments are representing on
that uh clean energy New Hampshire is
not a named member but we do uh attend
those meetings and they are getting
regular updates from the national uh
level agencies that have more resources
and are studying this issue uh what was
generally observed is that they were
saying the data is inconclusive and it
needs more study and so at this point it
feels premature we are uh supportive of
fire safety and do appreciate uh
representative Peru and Pearson's
contributions and dedication through
their time in the fire service but we
want to make sure we're not putting a
mandate on municipalities where they are
enforcing something that maybe the data
does not yet support and and so rather
than put this in place we would
recommend that it be sent to the
fire lithium battery fire Council um for
them to investigate similar to how we
send things to the building code review
board and the board of fire safety to
make recommendations to the building
code and the fire code before it comes
back to the House and Senate Edna
committees thank you any questions from
the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much thank you
chair would now like to recognize
Zeke
ISO got it um representing himself who's
opposing the bill who's asking for two
to three minutes so welcome to
Transportation sir hi thank you first
time I ever do this is very exciting um
my name is zeky I'm a resident of
Kensington very small town I will say I
have no uh background that would be able
to help me in this case in terms of
safety and like everything we hear from
fire departments about the safety of EVS
um but I do have engineering background
which I've used uh extensively when I uh
talk about these issues with the
community not just fires but uh people
concerned about all sorts of things with
EVS uh you know spontaneously Catching
Fire is one that is very interesting
because of course it's not what we're
talking about right we're talking about
when an EV is uh damage that will cause
a fire like this the incense of ev's uh
being so low the fire EV fire is being
so low compared to Ice uh as reported by
uh there's lots of research that has
been done on this but of course like
like we heard it's very difficult
sometimes to determine if the fire was
caused by something wrong with the EV
the point is that there was an EV fire
um it does all point to there being
significantly less fire uh risk of an
Eevee I have been uh in talks with our
fire department because I am trying to
understand from their point of view like
you know what what is the risk what is
the concern and a lot of times we talk
about Outdoors kington is very small we
definitely don't have any garages uh but
the concern seems to be what we heard uh
initially which was that uh putting out
an EV fire can take a lot of water uh
and when we're talking about a garage
that is something that I would hope is
taken into consideration when we're
talking about safety um what I'm
confused about after hearing everything
with comments about weight for example
um comparably speaking same size cars
are not that much different I just was
hoping that you all would know for
example Tesla Model 3 weighs uh roughly
as much as a BMW 300 series uh it's
3,800 lb 4,000 lb uh similar with uh
other cars but my point is in that it's
that wouldn't the garage need a way to
be able to figure out if the cars
they're allowing in are going to be
structurally damaging the structure
right like there are high limitations
that's a great way of doing it right a
very large diesel truck will probably
weigh more than a Tesla Model 3 as a
matter of fact I know that they do uh a
Hummer will probably not fit into the
Portsmith garage ice or EV right uh so
weights I'm not seeing the concern there
I would hope that the engineers behind
the garage would have a say in it not
the law right like laws are supposed to
be preventing things that are
unpreventable I would say um and so from
the from that point of view I really
don't understand why that argument is
brought up so often but I can understand
it right it's it is a concern if if the
weight is a problem um we should address
it I just don't think that the data is
there to back up that claim EV fires
again we've already heard the likelihood
of new EV fire is much lower so I don't
risk and um related to how we do risk
assessment I'm not qualified to do that
right but I would believe that given how
few EVS there are in New Hampshire and
even then the rate being 30 40 50 times
less likely that an Eevee catches fire
that we would take that into
consideration and as a matter of fact I
did do a little more research into that
uh in terms of insurance insurance is a
great way to know if these claims are
true or not right that's the market
speaking like yes we believe that EVS
are a worse uh they're they're worse for
us and as an insurance company uh and I
called them because uh I do regret to
say maybe not regret uh I have a little
bit of Shame sometimes when I speak
publicly I have a cyber truck a test of
cyber Tru which is very controversial
everybody knows that uh getting
insurance on it everyone was very
concerned that it was going to be a
problem uh turns out to be much cheaper
than my other cars which is surprising
but I did call the insurance company
because I wanted to know why right why
is it cheaper and aren't you guys
concerns with the fires uh and why is my
other car so much more expensive and
they said that they first of all the the
data isn't there yet so they are
catching up so if in the future this
does come up where it turns out that
fires EV fires are a big concern I'm
sure that they going to be insurance
companies speaking about this but so far
they don't think that's a reason at all
it's actually related to the complexity
of the cars themselves right if you bump
into a mailbox and it cost $10,000 to
fix because of all the technology in
there that's the insurance going up and
as it turns out a lot of the new cars
regardless of what engine they're
running have this problem so that's why
Insurance prices have been going up from
the research I've done again I'm not a I
I have no actual technical background in
this um and so I would definitely be
against the bill of course I drive only
electric cars a lot of my friends Drive
electric cars not being able to park in
the garage would suck I mean it's not
it's it's not terrible right there's
parking everywhere thankfully um other
than conquer it was impossible to find
parking here but uh where I am it's not
that big of a concern and and of course
if it makes it safer for everybody
totally makes sense but I do follow uh
the Rockingham uh emergency services and
there are fires all the time car fires
and I will say to date there have been
there's been one and it was actually
costed by an electric uh an ice car next
to it that caught fire and then the
older Tesla CAU fire due to that um yeah
that's that's sort of my what I would
like to say and of course please oppose
the bill I I don't see how how it would
be helpful at this point Thank you any
comments or any questions from the
committee representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question at one point um when we had
testimony prior uh on a prior bill um
same topic uh it was pointed out or it
was uh mentioned that the owner manuals
of the
EVS um indicated that they would prefer
um fast charging only be done in
emergencies or are are you aware of such
a comment inside your inside your safety
manual uh no that that is not something
that I've seen recommended I've actually
read a lot of the the manuals because
there are sometimes there are concerns
that people get confused about well if
it says it in the manual why aren't
people following it a great example is
car washes you might have heard that
people say that you shouldn't run an EV
through a car wash because they will
destroy it uh that's a very popular one
and it's turns out the manual does say
to be to be careful with automatic car
washes um but it turns out that it's for
reasons that people don't totally
understand because most cars have Car
Wash mode which will disable that in
terms uh it'll disable the the features
that would cost issues like the uh gas
or the the EV charging port opening up
mid uh washing which would then get
water into the charge board which could
damage the electronics not a safety
concern because everything is grounded
properly usually uh but again in terms
of the manual talking about charging not
at all uh technically speaking right if
we did actually get into the specifics I
usually don't because people don't like
to hear Math and Science but uh DC
charging fast charging level three we're
talking uh 800 amps usually 400 volts
right so uh this is anywhere up to 250
kilow this is a large three-face direct
current Transformer that is installed
usually uh to power these it's it's not
new equipment right this has been around
for 50 60 80 years uh the all the rage
about uh safety with EVS is not really
grounded on usually on the data um it
seems to be more on user error or
sometimes really bad Hardware right like
you do get bad Hardware all across the
industry on every type of uh electrical
equipment but the safety features have
gone a long way these past few years
right a charger will not let you the
Tesla charger that I have for example it
will not let you charge if it's not
properly grounded it can detect that
right I can't say the same
for uh you know every piece of uh
charging equipment that every EV has but
I will be very surprised if it was
actually a a widespread concern thank
you any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much chair now like to recognize Jessica
Wilcox for the the New Hampshire
Dees who is asking for 3 to five minutes
don't know if you support or oppose the
bill welcome to Transportation thank you
honorable honorable chair and members of
the committee Jessica Wilcox with the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services and for Dees um I
oversee a bureau that is uh focused on
Transportation programs and projects a
lot of which funding goes to our
municipalities and such so we've been
putting a lot of money out there
um Dees takes no specific position on
this bill but wants to offer some
information and resources for
consideration so Chris goland mentioned
in the 2024 legislative session Senate
Bill 430 was passed which established an
electric vehicle in lithium ion battery
study Council that is chaired by the
State Fire Marshall Shan Tumi um Dees
has a position on that on that uh
Council as well and that council is
tasked with study among other issues the
impacts to the built environment um and
will'll ultimately be making
recommendations using evidencebased data
so the interim report was submitted on
November 1st of 2024 and there is a
final report that is due this November
so based on de's analysis of some 2024
New Hampshire uh Department of Motor
Vehicle vehicle registration data of the
nearly 1.7 million vehicles that are
currently register registered in New
Hampshire
approximately 14,700 of those are
electric
vehicles EV fire occurrence in New
Hampshire is low and per data from the
Senate Bill 430 interim report um the
insurance department actually requested
data from their industry in mid July of
last year and a survey of the largest 10
Underwriters of private passenger auto
insurance in New Hampshire for the
period of January 20th through June 2024
showed the total number of fire claims
related to battery electric vehicles was
three the total number of fire claims
related to battery hybrid vehicles was
one so that's a period of 2020 of
January 2020 through June of
2024 the State Fire Marshals office also
perform some data drilling into
narratives of reports that were
submitted to the National fire incident
reporting system over the past two years
the State Fire Marshall's office is
aware of five vehicle fires three of
which were the result of accidents and
this is compared to approximately 400
vehicle fires reported in New Hampshire
each year so this council is researching
and documenting data that pertains to
the impacts of EVS on the safety and
structural soundness of a parking garage
as per the interim report the
International Code Council UL Fire
Safety Research Institute Factory mutual
and the NFPA fire protection Research
Foundation all have studies underway to
evaluate these impacts on parking
garages it's anticipated that these
results from these studies are expected
in the coming year so kind of what I'm
building up to is there's a lot of
research happening and this Council that
that I'm participating in Senate Bill
430 is looking to kind of gather up all
that research and package that in that
in that final report so therefore Dees
does ask that the committee consider
referring this bill to interim study and
allow the Senate Bill 430 Council to
complete this work and just a few
additional considerations
so during the 2024 legislative session a
similar Bill HB 1332 FN relative to
prohibiting EVS from parking and parking
garages Was Heard and was ultimately
voted itl and that didn't specify
commercial parking garages so that's
something unique to this to this piece
of
legislation um additionally existing
parking structures are likely sufficient
for future electric vehicle loads and
this is per a July 2024 scholarly
article us building codes have long
recommended designing parking garage
floors for what are called live loads
and these are loads that are subject to
change right because cars are moving
around um those live loads generally are
about 40 pounds per square foot and so
this is how parking garages have been
structured so they're already
anticipating that this is there's going
to be some flexib fluctuation there and
some flexibility so they're already
designed to take the expected future
electric vehicle loading I can give you
a link to that article after this um in
followup to this the weight of an EV
does impact its battery range so
although there are concerns about EVS
being so heavy automakers have an
urgency to lighten that load right to
reduce their weight and they're
continually working on ways to reduce
that weight so what we're seeing is the
exponential battery progress of Battery
Technology is likely going to result in
electric vehicles eventually becoming
lighter Dees did perform a did perform a
curb w comparison of the top highest
selling electric vehicles and their
comparable gasoline counterparts and
what we found is that on average there's
a difference of approximately a th000
pounds and I can kind of give you that
breakdown as
well additionally we're starting to see
vehicle weight Trends in general
increasing right this is called car blo
um the average vehicle weight over the
last uh 40 years has increased by a
thousand by approximately a th000 pounds
and in the United States as most people
know City and station wagons and pickup
trucks have largely replaced um or SUVs
and pickup trucks have largely replaced
SED Dan and station wagons they now
account for about four in every five new
car purchase um at the same time
individual vehicle models are getting
heavier we talk about all that new
technology that's coming on board right
a 2024 Chevrolet Silverado pickup for
instance is around 700 lbs heavier and 2
in taller than the 1995 Edition so we're
seeing that vehicles are increasingly
getting heavier
and according to Federal data the
average new American car now weighs
around 30% more than it did 40 years ago
um but if parking garage are structured
to anticipate this weight growth which
is what we're reading um they're
prepared to manage that that increase so
vehicle weight Trends did ini initially
decrease but have been in steadily uh
steadily increasing over the years
earlier from model year 1975 to 81
average vehicle weight actually dropped
21% from 4,60 lb per vehicle to about
3200 lb so parking garages built in the
1970s they were accommodating that 4,000
lound weight and what we're seeing on
average is for most um electric vehicles
4,000 lbs is kind of the the average the
average weight uh so model year 2004
average new vehicle weight has actually
increased across the board 28% and
currently has reached about 4,000 lbs
per vehicle that's ice if you will
internal combustion engine as well as
Electric
vehicle um with all of this information
in mind and in consideration of the
continuing good work of the Senate Bill
430 Council Dees does ask that the
committee consider referring this bill
to interim study and certainly I'm happy
to provide this information
electronically with links to these
resources a copy of the Senate Bill 430
interim report if that would please the
committee that's all I have to share
today thank you that would be great if
you can get that to us any questions
from the committee representative
Fox thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question did did I hear
correctly that of the approximately 400
vehicle fires in New Hampshire each year
that for the first half of last year
there were three that involved an
electric vehicle so over the past two
years the State Fire Marshalls Office is
aware of five electric vehicle fires
three of which were the result of
accidents and that's compared to the 400
or so fires reported in New Hampshire
every year so on an annual basis about
400 in the past two years five electric
follow up follow up and were any of
those in a commercial parking lot do you
know that I don't know but the State
Fire Marshal's Office may they collected
that data so I can certainly ask them
thank you any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much thank you very much for your time
do you have written testimony as well
it's not it was informally written but
I'm certainly happy to provide it as a
followup okay that would be great thank
with that I don't see any anybody else
who wants to testify so I'm going to
close the hearing on HB 182 our next
bill just give a few few minutes will be
there there is the opportunity uh to
afterwards um I would add it in in
this one going
all right being uh 11:47 like to open up
the hearing on HB 260 creating a
commemorative license plate celebrating
the
250th anniversary of Bunker Hill and the
chair would like to recognize
representative
Pearson welcome back the prime sponsor
all right this will be a lot more
fun for the record Representative Steve
Pearson Rockingham District 13 which is
encompasses is the town of
dairy so what house bill 260 is looking
to do is to to create a one-year
commemorative state plate in honor of
the 250th anniversary of the Battle of
Bunker
Hill um I am a published historical
author not not on the Revolutionary War
um so I
was I'm going to give you a very very
brief background and why this is
important and its connection certainly
to New Hampshire so um the Battle of
Bunker Hill
occurred on June um excuse me the 16th
and into the 17th of June in 1775 250
years ago coming up uh the battle Bunker
Hill occurred during the BOS the British
occupation of the city of Boston on the
night of the 16th in 1775 American
forces set up a fortification on breeds
Hill so as to be able to um fire cannon
into the city of Boston Boston was
heavily occupied by British troops but
they were blockaded by American forces
on the neck Boston used to be a
peninsula in in the 1700s it was
substantially filled in later so there
was a a narrow neck American forces had
Boston and they had occupied what was
called Dorchester Heights at the time
which was also smooshed to make the Back
Bay and other other parts of the city
this fortification on Bunker Hill would
have been a big advantage to American
forces while
constructing this the war once it was
discovered warships within Boston Harbor
began firing on the hill while they were
constructing the fort amazingly only one
person was killed during the
fortification in the morning British
forces set foot on Charles toown neck
which was was also a peninsula at the
time and the British Set Fire to the to
Charlestown literally Set Fire to the
hill soldiers and militia men because we
did have a continental army at the time
it was very in very early formations um
on the Battle of Bunker Hill were from
Massachusetts Connecticut Rhode Island
and New
Hampshire notably from New Hampshire the
first and third New Hampshire regiments
under the commands of Colonel John Stark
and Colonel James Reed Stark would later
become the hero of the battle in
Bennington and made made a general so
much is his importance to our history
that he is one of the few that has a
statue out front of the State
House now the Battle of Bunker
Hill was actually the deadliest battle
of the Revolutionary War and it occurred
right at the
beginning 135 Patriots were killed 305
were wounded 226 British were killed and
825 British were wounded in this
battle despite technically being a
British victory that came at a massive
cost to the British
forces so the event showed that an
inexperienced American militia could
stand up to the British army which at
the time was considered the greatest
army in the
world this was the first allout war of
the Revolution we hear of of Lexington
had conquered we hear of some of the
other things that occurred minor
skirmishes but this was full-on
signified a major event in the history
of our nation and to our state the list
of notable people who fought at Bunker
Hill is an amazing read I won't read it
but it's literally the folks that were
there formed the beginning of this
nation one of whom who was killed was
was General Warren Dr Warren Dr Warren
was so instrumental at the beginning of
the Revolutionary War and so popular
that it is argued that he may have been
our first
president and he fell on Bunker Hill
so as we move forward in the next decade
of anniversaries of events and as we
celebrate the Revolutionary War in the
beginning of this nation
um this this event really from a New
Hampshire standpoint stands
out and um it was it was the wisdom of
Reed and Stark that
saw problems in the battle that and made
decisions that were substantial in in
keeping things um viable in the fight
the American forces ultimately lost
because we just simply ran out of
ammunition so um due to the substantial
historical significance of this event
due to New Hampshire's big role in this
event I thought it would make uh sense
under our statute to issue a one-year
commemorative plate for the Battle of
Bunker
committee representative Hill couldn't
let you get away thank you for my
question away without one question
um Beyond uh beyond the plate um and and
the recognition of the um is there any
purpose to the to the funding uh the
additional cost that this would take as
you saw in the bill the funding goes
towards the
Heritage U commission and and they'll do
with it as you know as they see fit um
this is not being done as as some sort
of a revenue producer by any stretch of
the imagination but um you know bringing
awareness
to um you know the the formation of of
this country bringing awareness to folks
that have no idea that we're even
entering into this 250th annivers period
in our country um is just you know aside
from showing a little bit of patriotism
and some pride as as to our New
Hampshire's involvement you know just
making folks aware of you know this is
this is the time period in our great
nation that we're going to be entering
into and and and according to um a lot
of historical folks and and and uh folks
down in DC a lot a lot is
coming follow up thank you Mr chairman
um
is Massachusetts issuing a a a plate do
you know I don't know Massachusetts
issues a lot of different plates for
things but I'm I'm not aware of of what
Massachusetts is doing um as far as that
goes thank you representative
Fox thank you Mr chair um I may have
missed this is there a a price of the
commemorative plate that you'll that
will that the that is handled by the by
the
DMV under their rules
follow follow is there an anticipated
sold no idea you know as you're aware
right our license plates today are
decals right I mean if you've ever seen
a delaminated license plate you you're
acutely aware of what happens you can
actually peel them apart um so as far as
you know the Department of Motor
Vehicles creating a um
some sort of a design for for that it's
it's the application of a decal that it
would be just in any of the other moose
plate or other decals that we put on a
license plate so I I this isn't this
doesn't incur substantial cost the DMV
is not even here to they're not clearly
not worried about it so um but yeah
that's that you know just through the
way we make license plates today it's
quite easy to to do that and you don't
you're not in a situation where you say
you stamp a thousand plates and we we
sell 50 right that those are cre on
demand just as our legislative plates
are representative
Jon yes thank you Mr chair so I'm just
noticing from the uh from the license
plate Bill we saw this morning with a
fiscal impact of $225,000 and yours
projected $10,000 for production are you
confident in that $10,000 because the
disparity between the two different
vanity plates seems dramatic to me I
have no idea what it cost to make a
vanity plate I do know that New
Hampshire per capita has the largest
vanity plate use in the country um we
we're very much into our vanity plates
in New Hampshire uh which is great every
single vehicle I own has a vanity plate
so um you know I'm certainly uh I've
certainly partake in that Revenue
producing Venture from the state um you
know and uh for seven years when I was
in college I lived in the state of
Oklahoma Oklahoma has
150 different license plates they make a
ton of money off their vanity plates so
this is just another just something a
little bit more unique than us seeing a
moose plate a veterans plate or a
National Guard plate say this is It's
just adding to that and again it's only
for a year it's only for one year so um
you know and it'll fall under under the
rules and regulations of of uh
commemorative plates that already
exist representative V thank you Mr
chairman thank you taking my question
why Bunker Hill and not the semi Quin
Centennial when New Hampshire was the
first to declare independence from the
crown U why you picked
Bunker Hill
over U the 250th anniversary which will
be coming up within less than 12 months
starting that year sure um I mean
realistically between the pine tree
riots and the Constitution being signed
I we've got thousands of events that
that could be potentially put on the
reason that Bunker Hill stands out is
because of it of it again being the
first full-on war at act the first
full-on actual engagement of a of
substantial battle um and also New
Hampshire's unique role in making that
event be as successful as it could have
been that this was the beginning it kind
of
launches um launches the the whole
Endeavor
and rather than just say have a
generic 250th Revolutionary War plate
right that this this the reason for
highlighting this is just because of it
New Hampshire's significant involvement
on in something that was just so
substantial it changed Bunker Hill
completely changed the british's the
British opinion on the farmers with
pitchforks mentality they had against
militia um it completely changed the the
way that the British
operated within their War tactics
but it also gave the
Americans hope for the first time that
holy cow we can
actually we may actually have something
here so that the significance of Bunker
Hill I think is is is enough to
Warrant it individually and that's why I
that's why I submitted the
legislation any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you sir
appreciate it thank you for your time
but no what else uh is on the pallet
we're going to close the hearing HB
260 we will be in recess till 1:00 where
hour
e
on uh h B
133 which is modifying the new Resident
driver license transfer requirements
specifying when the Division of Motor
Vehicle shall send violation notices and
appropriate funds to the division for
technical upgrades required for legal
compliance it's a lot to say there um
chairman like to recognize Andrew Prout
who is the Prime sponsor and for anyone
who has a written testimony if you do
have that please forward it to us so the
clerk can kind of post it accordingly um
during any time that year are testifying
representative Prout welcome to
Transportation thank you Mr chairman for
the record I Andrew Prout representing
Hillsboro County District 13 the town of
Hudson this bill is nearly the same as
House Bill 198 that was before this
committee last term with changes to
address feedback from the DMV received
after the bill passed over to the
Senate after retained by the senate
committee I didn't pursue it further
because because given the split in the
house membership last term and the
rework needed on the bill including
adding a fiscal note I was not
optimistic about its passage uh the
second half of last term went better
than I expected so I now somewhat regret
that decision but here we are uh a
version of this bill was also before the
this committee the term before as well
as House Bill
1643 this bill will amend RSA 26335 the
section that requires new residents to
transfer their out ofate driver's
license to an instate driver's license
to add additional reporting requirements
of a person's circumstances change
within those 60 days and direct the
department of safety to send reminder
letters to voters who presented out
ofate driver's licenses at the polls if
they failed to do
so the changes from last term are to
make an appropriation to the department
for it changes necessary for
implementation and a more clearly spell
out an implementation
timeline this bill is a follow-up to the
letter sent to then speaker Jasper on
September 6th 2017 by by the Secretary
of State and commissioner safety
reporting on the 2016 general election
in this letter A dismal
84.5% unexplained non-compliance rate
with the driver's license transfer
requirement was
reported I've worked with the secretary
of state and DMV director morasco and I
believe we have sufficiently addressed
the implementation concerns with this
bill I'd also like to stress that this
bill may just be a first step I
certainly plan to watch the statistics
for how many letters are sent and the
response rate I've warned director of
morasco that I'll be asking for those
numbers periodically once this gets
going but I feel that more intensive and
therefore more expensive measures can't
be justified without that data in hand I
submit a written testimony to the
committee that describes the bill in
more depth so I'll stop here and I'd be
happy to answer any questions the
committee may
have thank you so much any questions
committee I actually have one um in your
bill over in line
uh six where it says um or actually goes
into seven where it says
um shall have a maximum of 60 days from
the date of his or her residency was
established how does someone establish
their residency what do they need in
order to consider to be
established um so that part is existing
law and the when someone's moving into
the state you know there is I guess
theoretically as according to law a
magic moment at which they are now a New
Hampshire resident I feel like in
practice that's a little bit more fuzzy
and it has a lot to do with the person's
intent and their state of mind um and
it's very and that I think is part been
part of the problems in this space of
the residency requirements and
everything else is that trying to
objectively determine that exact moment
in time is not an easy task there's
certainly are certain events which we
expect you will have already passed that
threshold before you do voting is one of
them um there in the Supreme Court
opinion referenced in my uh written
testimony they go through a ly of other
events which that could also trigger
that um enrolling a child in school
getting a dumb permit other things that
are evidence that you have that has
already happened but in terms of uh
attempting to Define exactly when that
moment is for any given individual I'm
not sure there's an easy objective way
to do
that any other questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you sir thank
you chair would now like to recognize uh
Secretary State Mr David scandin who
supports the bill who uh like to speak
for two minutes welcome sir to
Transportation thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee I'm David
scanland Secretary of State and although
I do a lot of testifying before the
elections law committee um I don't often
get a chance to get out and meet the
other committee committees so it's a
pleasure to be here today to talk about
this bill
um it is not unusual when a voter
registers to vote for an out ofate
driver's license to be used to establish
identity uh in that
process um when that happens a notation
is made on the voter checklist uh and in
the the registration records that the
voter used that type of identification
process the law says that when a person
establishes residency in the state of
New Hampshire they have X number of days
to obtain a New Hampshire driver's
license if they're going to drive a
state when a voter uses an outof state
driver's license they are saying
that they have
established their residency in the state
of New Hampshire because you have to be
a resident uh to be able to vote in the
state the common word in the election
statute is domicile but the court has
said that it is effectively the same
thing there is no mechanism currently
for the Secretary of State to follow up
on those voters that used an outof state
license uh to register to vote to see if
they have in fact followed through with
the laws that residents are subject to
because the law is the law of a
different state agency in this case
Motor Vehicles it could be a fish and
game law if you know if that same voter
wants to you know get a fishing game
license or things like
that and so for that reason um I'm
supportive of the language in this bill
that would allow us to match the
information further than we currently
are obligated to match by federal and
state statute to determine the status of
those voters that used an out ofst state
driver's license for the voter
registration process and did they follow
up
um W with the laws of the State of New
Hampshire to actually obtain their
instate uh driver's
license and that's why I support the
bill so based on that I'd be happy to
answer any questions uh if there are
any thank you so much any questions from
the committee representative Hill thank
you Mr chairman and uh welcome uh to
house
Transportation um as I recall um when a
when a voter from my days in election
law um when a voter um is indicated it
comes to the table uh to CHS his license
and it's a Minnesota license um
the clerk is supposed to write MN next
to their name in red pencil I guess um I
recall seeing numbers of those uh as I
reviewed after an election um does
anyone follow up um currently to find
out if that person is using that same MN
I'm TR the best way to answer that
question if if they come in and use that
same license as their proof of
identity uh when they go to obtain their
license not registering but obtain their
license um I believe a notation is
supposed to be made on that but I don't
know that the the database is picking up
on you know has that voter obtained
the New Hampshire driver's license yet
um I I think this bill will help do that
um it's an area that really should be
focused on and um you know for the
members of the committee when a person
registers to vote they have to prove
four
things identity number one age they're
old enough citizenship are they United
States
citizen and then domicile are they a
resident uh of the state
up until just a few years ago a voter
could walk into the polling place
without any documentation of those items
and prove their qualifications simply by
filling out
affidavits uh the most recent law that
has passed related to that now requires
that when a voter shows up they actually
have to show the documentation of all
four of those items although identity
can still be a governmental uh ID from
state this bill will help make sure that
those individuals that use that type of
documentation have actually gone to the
next step and follow the law that
residents are required to follow by
obtaining a New Hampshire driver's
license uh if they are going to drive a
vehicle in the
state thank
you any other questions from the
committee representative Sykes thank you
Mr chairman thank you SEC uh secretary
scanland for joining us here in
transportation
um
the the uh notes for this bill indicate
some costs for the DMV but there's no
indication if there's any staffing or
costs associated for the Secretary of
State's office for this for
implementation of this data that you
will
subsequently under the terms of this
cost I would defer to my deputy
secretary aarin Hennessy who's sitting
behind me because she works on those
fiscal notes um if there is I don't
suspect that it would be much there is
already a
requirement uh through federal statute
that we have to match uh uh just match
data from the voter registration
database with motor vehicle records
looking for um
anomalies uh such as U you know same
name same birthday but maybe different
addresses so that we can get that
cleaned up um I there may be some
additional software cause costs involved
with
um you know going the step with uh you
know making sure that outof state
licenses are you know have been changed
over um I'd be happy to talk with the
director Motor Vehicles on those costs
and see if there's some way that we
could
help eron do you you have any comment on
that question okay do she want to
respond to the question on the fiscal
matter did you want to respond to F
question thank you that'd be helpful
Y and just for the record could you just
state your name and title Please good
afternoon everyone I am Aaron Hennessy I
am the deputy secretary of state and
part of my job is to do the fiscal notes
for all of the hundreds not quite
hundreds this year but many fiscal notes
that we get to our department for this
one it simply requires our department to
share the data for anyone who has used a
out of state driver's license to either
I believe it's to register or to vote
but it might just be to vote have to
look into exact exact language um and we
already have this information in our
database so that would be an easy data
share with the Department of Motor
course representative Hill thank thank
you and uh welcome Senator um is it
uh there already is a a link as I
recall whether it's nightly or not um
download link between DMV and C
State's office is that correct thank you
for the question representative I'd have
to get you the exact details on it I
know our office our heal America vote
office our Hava office does have a
communication link with the DMV um we
there are some federal requirements that
we have to meet but I don't know the
exact timing of that data sharing so
yeah I don't recall either quick
followup well we do have the director
morasco and Jen Bailey up next so thank
you I one okay um are there there any
other links um for other agencies
similar um than DMV for secretary St for
yes thank you for the question not that
I can think of off the top of my head
I'll remember something later tonight
probably but no not that I'm aware
of any other questions from the
committee yes if you can fill out a pink
slip for us we much appreciate it thank
much just this point the chair like to
recognize uh director morasco or Jen
DMV they're flipping a
coin
okay doesn't say if you support or
oppose the bill but thank you Mr chair
and uh myself uh John morasco director
of the DMV here with this assistant
director Jen Bailey uh we're both
available to take any questions that may
come up um like to uh first thank
representative Prout for um reaching out
in advance and we've had some uh lengthy
conversations about his bill and uh he's
educated me quite a bit on Election law
and um how it would fit into what he's
trying to do here with this bill I want
to thank you for that sir it was uh
those were great conversations and um so
in reading the bill uh ultimately to to
representative Hill's question
um we we do have that communication with
Secretary of State there there is
information that goes from the DMV there
uh to update records uh with Secretary
of State's office um so this bill would
require uh the opposite it would require
that um based on my understanding when
somebody votes and they use an outof
state license if they have residency in
New Hampshire but they're using that out
ofate license um this bill would after
the uh 60 days has passed um with an
additional 30 of a buffer so in total 9
days um there would have to be a
notification from Secretary of State's
office through a batch file to the DMV
which would then come in um and at that
point what we could do is uh configure
the system to monitor uh those names
that are entered uh up against does that
person um get a New Hampshire driver's
license um you know I'm going to leave
it to the it experts on how we're going
to deconflict that information um but
that's something that uh that we can
work through um so our role would be
deconflict figure out how many have
actually got the New Hampshire license
how many have not those that have not uh
based on the bill would get a notice
from the DMV advising them that they
haven't fulfilled the requirement of
obtaining a New Hampshire license after
voting uh with a not estate license and
then there's a responsibility on the
DMV's part to track that information and
to take in those responses however they
might come in which I think is something
that we're still going to work through
which would be is this something where
we're taking in emails and there is a
fiscal note for a full-time position to
manage this program uh my understanding
from speaking with representative proud
is that you could have a couple thousand
several thousand uh after an election
that might have to be vetted out this
way uh so you would need somebody that's
going to be able to take that
information in and review it and um and
identify whether or not um there's any
further action and that was a question I
had for the representative what action
is there if they don't respond to the
DMV and uh my understanding is at this
point there is none um it's more for for
um analysis data Gathering research um
and could set the stage for a phase 2
Bill uh or an add-on to this bill that
that could um have a little bit more
enforcement behind it but as far as
making the bill work um based on uh
what's here I think we could fulfill it
uh with what's in the fiscal note for
somebody that could manage it
um and I'm happy to take any
questions any questions from the
committee or representative Hill thank
you Mr chairman thank you director um if
someone came in um
after uh that that notice was sent to
them um but six months eight months
later um I don't think the bill speaks
to any penalty or any um punitive
damages for for doing it not within a
timely fashion is that is that what
currently someone could come in 5 years
years later um now correctly that's my
understanding so I mean there's a grace
period That's cited in the bill um you
know if somebody goes beyond the 90 days
there's still the director's discretion
on um a grace period if you're working
through a situation where you might get
a response from someone um but again if
they don't respond uh there's nothing in
the bill that requires additional
followup or there could be a sanction of
any sort uh the other thing we did talk
about uh the representative I and I was
um it's Tethered to the license and
although somebody voted with a not
estate license um there is the
possibility that uh they are a New
Hampshire resident but they don't come
in to get a New Hampshire license
because they don't need one they don't
want one um so you would have a notice
that then goes out to an individual
saying you voted you use an out ofate
license you haven't you know obtained a
New Hampshire license why and um so we
talked about could that be beyond the
scope of the DMV is that a letter that
we should be sending I mean we're
reactive you know driving is a privilege
getting a license is a privilege people
come to us if they want that privilege
and go through the testing to get the
license um voting is something totally
separate than what we do um so somebody
goes to vote in this vein but then
they're getting a letter from the DMV
over here saying hey we've been keeping
an eye on this and we noticed that you
haven't got a New Hampshire license but
you voted over here with a Mass license
um we did talk about if that goes beyond
the scope of what the DMV should be
doing um because I don't I don't know
maybe maybe that person got a non-driver
ID uh maybe that person um was a
resident here in New Hampshire and to
your point representative Hill went
beyond the 90 days uh was a resident at
the time they voted and then moved back
to Massachusetts but now they're getting
a letter from our office saying you
haven't got your New Hampshire license
and their response may be well first of
all how do you know and secondly why you
sending me this letter because I know I
don't have one I don't want one um so
that was the one piece we talked about
in those select cases that could be an
overreach Paul thank you Mr chairman um
I recall from my days in election law
that um when when I should have probably
asked uh secretary about it but there
there were a number of people that used
outof state licenses for years um and
and I'm wondering if um this letter goes
out and then the second year this person
pops back up on on your your list maybe
that's when um someone needs to step in
and take other action whether it's the
secretary or whether it's the director I
don't know but um maybe maybe that was
the way to look at it I don't know yeah
more it's a good point not a question
more a statement yeah any other
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you sir
thank you Mr
chair chair I I like to recognize Olivia
zinc who is from open
democracy who was seeking two minut
minutes who is opposing the bill welcome
to Transportation good afternoon um
chairman and members of the transport
Transportation committee I'm normally an
election law so um my name is Olivia
zinc I'm a voter in Franklin um and um o
represent open democracy we're a
nonpartisan nonprofit um representing
36,000 voters um across the state I want
to start with a story um I this year I I
work at the elections uh as I'm also a
city councelor so that makes me a
Selectmen and so um they asked the PE
body place came in with a van from the
nursing home of some voters and they
asked for some help wheeling in some
voters so I had the honor and privilege
of wheeling in a voter who used a main
driver's license to vote who is in a
nursing home in Franklin already
registered on the checklist with 24p
body place which is the address of the
nursing home but used a main driver's
license the voting law says if you're
over 65 and you have an expired driver's
license you can still continue to use an
expired driver's license um and so what
my question for you is with this bill
will we
require residents of nursing home to
then get a New Hampshire driver's
license in order to continue to vote um
where they are now residing and and just
to remind you that you can be domiciled
you know your identity when voting is
just to prove this picture is
me the the folks are checking to make
sure the names are the same and domicile
is proved through other
mechanisms um I also want I have a
neighbor down the street from me that
that has recently moved in I see them
drive by with Connecticut plates I still
know they live in my neighborhood um but
have they sold their house in
Connecticut when when are they
officially um I think that the question
was asked by the chair earlier of when
does that residency requirement happen
but if they bought a house and they
voted
and they're they're living on my street
but still driving their Connecticut
plates I I think there is a point where
you do have to change your driver's
license so those individuals do need
those letters but I think there are
other voters blind voters voters with
disabilities uh voters that might not
have a a non-driver's identity um who
are using um other forms of physical IDE
identification I do want to speak to
military voters because military voters
do have exemptions if they're placed in
different places they do not have to to
get a new driver's license every time
they're stationed and so they may be
people that are here on temporary
assignment through a military um and and
vote here because they're they're
domiciled here for for that year um but
are voting with an out of state driver's
license so I do think we need to take
into consideration all of these concerns
um and um I urge you to think about uh
those voters uh who may be elderly or
disabled or have non- drivers
identification um because they still
have the constitutional right to vote if
they're eligible voters um uh so I urge
you to itl this this bill um and
consider equal access to the ballot for
those um New Hampshire citizens and
happy to take any questions thank you
any questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much with that I have no other people
who are scheduled to to testify so at
this point I'm going to close the
hearing on HB
133 our next bill will be HB
minutes
e
okay be it uh 133 I'm going to call the
hearing into session on HB
258 establishing a study commission to
determine the Readiness of the New
Hampshire Sea Coast emergency evacuation
plan chair recognizes
representative saborin who is sponsor of
the bill welcome to Transportation
representative good good afternoon
chairman Gorski and members of the
committee I'm a representative Sabor d
schaner That's a full last name I'm from
Rockingham District 30 in C Brook as the
prime sponsor I'm introducing HP 258
establishing us a commission to
determine the Readiness this New
Hampshire SE Coast emergency Evac plan
uh my district the host Community to the
largest nuclear power plant in New
England is exploring options for
updating its emergency flood plan in
response to the increasingly frequent
and severe flooding of State Route 286
with a notable example being the
flooding of January 2024 and the fossil
arm incident at at the nuclear power
plant in the summer of 20122 last year's
floods resulted in the Beach District
being locked out in panic for 6 hours
unable to evacuate or be able to receive
any first responder emergency
services this is anticipated to be a
multi-year project with various
stakeholders taking part the town of
seab Brook via our planning board is
coordinating with the neighboring towns
of Hampton New Hampshire in Salisbury
Massachusetts right now who also face
similar catastrophes along with the
Rockingham Planning Commission and the
New Hampshire Department of
Transportation uh with several
productive meetings having already
occurred various federal grants are in
consideration and the study commission
is requested to Aid in the effort uh
I've attempted to list all the
stakeholders Who We Believe will need to
be consulted as members of this
commission if the committee determines
that additional entities should be
included from more comprehensive final
product we would not object and I did
submit an amendment to this bill that
included additional members of the
committee it looks like the uh I got the
email this morning um OS says oops um
please note that the amended copy
contains the unapproved Watermark once
OS is notified that the amendment has
been officially adopted by Committee
Action or let remove the watermark and
release the amendment to the clerk and
the amendment that has been requested is
simply just a few more additions to the
members of the committee uh listed in
the bill um I do have some exhibits I
can show you guys um this is what has
been mailed out to all of our seab Brook
residents from next ERA this is the
there is an Evac plan in place for um in
the event there is a you know a nuclear
incident at our power plant if there's
an accident at our power plant um but
we're looking at a you know a
combination of of of of let's say
there's weather and uh nuclear I could
and additionally as for further exhibits
I also have brought photographs that our
our local police department took of the
sir is that can we use can we give that
to the clerk for our for for our records
yes please yeah that's fine yeah okay
yeah any questions from the committee
representative
Sykes thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question um
can you tell me I I'll it'll be in two
parts if it's all right Mr chairman um
can you tell me who the new members are
the your Amendment would add oh yes
because I had questions about that and I
may not need to ask one yep so
um one rep one one member representing
the New Hampshire division of Homeland
Security Emergency Management one member
representing next era energy CBR station
one member representing the town of CBR
selectman pardon me while I just write
some notes okay that's fine um thank you
for that have you one of the things that
caught my attention and just because of
uh some of my other volunteer activities
is that in a um genuine nuclear power
plant incident
um there'd be a huge need for evacuation
correct and then those people have to go
someplace and um I know I spent several
years working on Vermont's
uh nuclear power plant evacuation back
when they had uh the one in Vernon uh
and a big consideration
was uh Sheltering for the people who had
to evacuate and so the American Red
Cross was particularly involved in
providing Sheltering for uh those folks
and I wondered if that would be
something that had has does the would
would they be a a would that be a good
addition to your
membership I believe
so I'm not gonna I'm not not going to
say no to that that's a yeah I just my
experience says that people going to
have to go someplace and so one and and
yeah generally shelters are operated by
many nonprofits but the primary
nonprofit operator of Sheltering in the
country is the American Red Cross so I
just throw that out as a thank you yes
sir um if you'd be amenable to that I
might no no no objections okay thank you
represented Hill thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my
question um I'm not a huge F of
commissions anyway I've never seen one
that did anything any good um but I um
kind of surprised that there isn't such
a thing already or or perhaps as I'm
reading this um maybe there already is
this organization because it appears
like they're determining the Readiness
of the plan so someone must have created
the plan at some point this is just to
reexamine the plan is that how I
understand this
so
um sorry no it's okay
um
um I I guess the current plan is in need
of an update and we're looking for State
support in in
this we're right now work you know we
had a big meeting a few weeks ago with
our planning board we invited the towns
of of and Salsbury and the depart New
Hampshire Department of Transportation
was there the rocking and Planning
Commission was there and and this is
know it's starting at the at the bottom
level right now and this is kind of
to When when when when when that plan is
ready to be added to the 10e plan this
commission or or or committee if it
turns out to be a better way to go about
things would be there to help supplement
that that 10year plan follow up thank
you
um so it sounds if I'm understanding you
correctly it sounds like they you you're
on the way to building yes an a
commission existing um organically and
and now you're just looking for us to
put a stamp of approval on having this
commission is that the purpose well the
state support for
it
State got to say I'm U no I I'm puzzled
but um I appreciate your answers okay we
could always meet on a follow up on
another time and come back with more
yeah okay any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much okay thank you everybody thank you
so
much chair now would like to recognize
Kristen Evans from AEL New Hampshire
who
oh okay never mind
well I have nobody else uh for 258 so at
this point I will close the hearing on
HB
258 our next bill will be HB 259 in
thank you Mr chair uh thank you to the
uh Transportation Committee in which I
uh
apologies
e
okay via 203 I'd like to call um the
hearing for HB 259
which is relative to increasing the
number of handicap license plates and
placards the Department of Motor
Vehicles May issue to
individuals and at this time the chair
like to recognize representative
pataro who is the Prime sponsor the
sir thank you Mr chair and thank you to
the transportation committee for uh
hearing me today and and uh my name is
representative Matthew barar I represent
Allenstown merat County District 11 I am
pretty much beginning my second
non-concurrent term and starting my
second term here on the transportation
committee and I'm very proud of the work
that we've done and that we're
doing and um my bill HB 259 the impetus
for it was my father who is handicapped
and his story is kind of interesting
interesting he ran into a situation
where
um there's a limit to the combination of
the number of handicap plates and
handicap placards that an individual
household can get so in his particular
case at the time he could only get one
plate and one placard and what he chose
to do was get the handicap plate for his
motorcycle and use the placard for his
daily driver
and very soon after that he was required
to go on a business trip for work and he
realized that he didn't want to bring
his motorcycle to the parking lot at the
airport and had he brought his daily
driver his uh four-wheel vehicle to the
airport uh he wouldn't be able to park
in the handicap section of the airport
he'd have to park further away the
reason being is that with his placard he
would have to bring the placard with him
to where he was going on the business
trip so for the rental he could park in
a handicap spot so that's just basically
a little bit of the background here and
what my bill does is it completely
eliminates the limit to the number of
handicap plates an individual can get
already with this bill being filed there
has been some feedback I've received and
concerns concerning the
um uh number of placards that an
individual can get largely those
concerned are centered around um abuse
of the placard system and so forth um
but despite the the the the summary on
the bill where it mentions both plates
and placards if you look at the language
of the bill the language of the bill and
the section that IT addresses only
addresses the
plates and that is the intent that I
wanted when I filed the
bill purely philosophically speaking if
an individ ual is handicapped but they
nonetheless are a let's say successful
individual let's say said individual has
a fleet of 20 vehicles that they like
they register them all why not have all
the vehicles be equipped with a handicap
plate I I feel that the handicap
designation should be designated to the
individual not to the household or the
number of cars that they have or
anything like that it to me if if
somebody's handicapped they should uh be
able to designate each of their vehicles
if they register with a handicap
plate so I feel that this is fairly
straightforward and um I'm interested to
hear more feedback on this as it as it
goes through the process and I welcome
anybody's
questions thank you any questions from
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman and thank you taking my
question representative um do you have
any thoughts on um people that operate
as Caregivers for
um special needs or handicapp people um
that need um they need to get someone
closer to the um a place and help them
walk into the doctor's office or
something like that um do you do you
think that there's any room in your bill
for expansion so that it would be more
helpful to those
caregiving thank you representative uh
that is that is a great question um I
kind of have uh two quick answers to
that
um
um my my grandmother she's 90 years old
and um loves SL machines and uh as she's
gotten on in years uh you know through
rotation it's my job to bring her to uh
Twin River and Lincoln Rhode Island and
and uh one of the one of the key key
things about that Adventure is making
sure that we have her handicap placard
and you know it's a little bit more
convenient for me to use it and help her
and get the wheelchair from the casino
drop her off and all all the things that
come along with being a one day
caregiver for somebody with mobility
issues a walking walking
disability
um to answer your question directly I'm
learning as since I filed this and from
some of the Outreach I've gotten from
some of the different organizations that
there are so many facets and so many
angles to um disability law and there's
all sorts of work to be done I do not
think that addressing the complexities
of what may or may not be going on in
terms of the
placards would be
appropriate as an amendment let's say to
this bill I think
that the wide spectrum of disability
laws that we have we can attack more on
an individual basis some of these issues
and and keep keep the walls up with with
areas representative kaon
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
representative so am I correct in my
interpretation of the current law that
it is I've heard one license plate per
person I've heard one per household am I
correct in the understanding that if uh
if two disabled persons occupy the same
household that one could get denied a
plate if the other one has a licensed
plate due to domicile is that
correct thank you for the question
representative gas um to my knowledge
the answer to that question and your
understanding is correct uh in fact I've
uh spoken to a uh couple of Advocates
who are in said situation and they did
run into that very roadblock when both
um the the spouses uh sitting behind me
right here in fact um they both have uh
a walking disability and they did run
into some headwinds when they each
wanted to get a handicap plate for each
of their cars um again I want to defer
to what I mentioned earlier about the
philosophical aspect of this why not why
can't an handicapped individual have a
handicap plate for every one of their
cars um thank
you any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you sir
thank
you chair now would like to recognize
Melinda
Sims who is from United spinal
um who wanted about three minutes and I
talked to her earlier and I don't know
if you are for or against the bill
because you said you're kind of going
back and forth based on new information
Transportation thank you chair and
members of the committee for allowing me
to speak today in opposition of the bill
um I speak uh I just learned that um
this is supposed to be about plates and
not placards yet it's it's listed here
on on the bill as plates and placards so
I'm going to speak to that fact um I I
am uh The Advocate coordinator for
United spinal here in New Hampshire but
I also uh work under Federal we also
work with the access board um and uh
we're working with them and making the
2010 changes up to date so um I'm going
to just read
this the while the desire for additional
convenience is understandable we must
carefully consider the broader
implications of this proposed change let
me explain the serious concerns this
bill would create for our state New
Hampshire has 166,000 residents with
disabilities and it's important to note
that this number includes all types of
dis abilities not just those requiring
parking
accommodations yet we currently have
over
680,000 permanent parking placards in
circulation that's 30
1% more permanent parking placards than
our total disabled
residents our current rate of 60.2 seven
placards per 100 population drastically
exceeds the national Benchmark of
5,168 excess Standalone permanent
placards above our total disabled
population the impact of this
oversaturation is severe 52% of disabled
individuals report having to cancel
activities due to parking
unavailability the International parking
and Mobility Institute has documented
serious problems with expanding placard
numbers at Hampton Beach State Park the
recent accessible study found accessible
spaces being occupied for even up to 24
hours blocking access to others and
reducing local business
Revenue even more concerning
investigations have revealed these
placards are being sold illegally online
on the Black Market at 250 a piece
adding more placards would only
intensify these existing problems our
current system already has a simple
solution when someone gets a disability
plate they also get a portable
placard they can move between vehicles
with that placard according according to
the United spinals association's best
practices this approach works well just
keep the placard in a purse or on a key
rack or something and transfer it to
whichever vehicle you're using this way
people have the flexibility they need
while preventing misuse of these vital
parking spaces the New Hampshire chapter
of United spinal Association is happy to
meet with you and share more details
about our research we'd also like to
encourage consultation with the
governor's Commission on disability for
their views on this important issue
thank you for your time and I'm happy to
answer any
questions thank you any questions from
the
committee representer
Fox thank you Mr
chair do you have any idea how how that
can possibly be with 166 ,000
disabled um residents in New Hampshire
and
68,000 placards what I I don't how could
how does that happen well what we
surmise is that the software programs
that DMV has needs to be
updated um if you go if you look at the
Illinois Illinois is um a poster child
for the parking and and placards uh
programs what they did is they uh made
up four new placards they did a went to
a two-tier system and then they recalled
all the
placards gave everybody their new
placards and then anybody left over with
the old placards the police confiscated
them now we start a new the new software
came into the state and they were able
to keep track of all of the placards
that were coming and going it's really
difficult it's like voting when someone
dies or moves or whatever it's very
difficult to keep track of those
placards but the new system has a code
bar they would be able to scan the
police could go up to a car and just
quickly scan that and know exactly who
owns that plaer if it's being abused or
if it's been stolen um we have online
doctors
that uh give out disability placards now
and we have uh people going on Amazon
you can look on Amazon and just order a
placard uh if they're rampant so my big
concern with this is if we increase
these plates we're going to increase
placards now there is one option if he
wants to say I have 10
cars and I want a plate for every car
you can purchase a specialty dis um
accessible plate for each of those
Vehicles it's
$50 but we need something written in the
rules that they cannot get a placard for
each one of those too because then those
10 placards are going to be abused
somehow he might drop them getting out
of the car the grandchild might grab it
and use it for their
car so we need to re that stuff in
[Music]
so thank you for your
question any other questions from the
committee I actually have one yes
um how does I guess my question is how
this my brother has a disability he has
a
placard I guess what I'm asking is why
did he get a placard versus
plates is there a reason why someone
would get plates versus a placard and
someone else gets a placard versus a
plate absolutely it's it's what they
requested you have the option of asking
for either one of them so whoever filled
out the
application um put down what what they
thought was
best all right thank you you're welcome
thank you for question any other
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
you okay the chair now would like to
recognize representative
Howard who is in support of the
bill and is asking for three minutes
welcome back to Transportation
representative thank you Mr chair and
thank you honorable committee members
for having me yet again uh my name is
representative Heath Howard I represent
the towns of straford and barington in
straford District 4 uh I'm in support of
h259 because uh as the representative
who introduced The Bill had stated it
affects plates only and as somebody who
has a mo mobility disability I broke my
back when I was 16 I had an L4 burst
fracture uh and I've needed uh handicap
placards ever since the thing is is that
we're not talking about the placards in
this situation and that's a separate
part of the RSA I do have uh the section
that is affected here which is RSA
26188 uh and it the language in the bill
says explicitly a person with a walking
disability may receive uh separate
special number plates for each motor
vehicle owned by a person it has nothing
to do with the placards so that is why
I'm in support of this as somebody who's
family owns four different types of
vehicles it is something where it is
kind of playing uh a jug Ling game of
trying to figure out where I need to put
my placard uh the next day but it's
something where as a younger person as
somebody who has my uh my mental uh
faculty still in place there are older
individuals who do need these disability
placards where they do need to move it
from car to car and sometimes they might
mess up it's easier if we just allow
these people to have the plates on the
front of their vehicle because then they
will never be able to forget it uh with
that being said uh I'm open to any
questions thank you thank you any
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you sir
thank
you chair now would like to recognize uh
Rod Sims who's representing himself
who's requesting three minutes who is
also opposing the bill welcome to
Transportation good afternoon committee
my name is Rod Sims I'm the husband of
Melinda Sims and her full-time caregiver
um my concern is the way we see the
wording it's it includes placards and
right now since I'm the one that usually
does most of the driving and stuff uh
give you a day in my life sometimes
we'll have to leave an hour or a half an
hour at least uh to allow time to go
find an adequate parking place at one of
her doctor's visits because um I'll pull
in and we have a very large van she has
that her chair weighs 450 pounds without
her in it we have a commercial lift in
this van and when it deploys you have to
have the very large deployment area
um we'll pull up to some place and it'll
say van parking place and you'll see a
little Toyota Corolla parked in there so
we may have to sit there for a half hour
or an hour to wait for the individual
who's parking in the van parking spot to
come out and move their vehicle now they
don't have a license plate saying
disabled but they have a placard laying
up on the dash because I'll literally
get out and look to see if they have a
disability plate displayed someplace and
I sat there and wait for this person to
come out so now you see this guy that's
probably 177 18 years old skipping out
of this building walking with no obvious
disability whatsoever come out and get
in these car pull out and leave so to
me we've got too many plates floating or
we got too many placers floating around
that people are abusing don't know how
they're getting if grandma died Grandpa
died and they took their their placard
we don't know but our system right now
doesn't do a good job of
monitoring where the placards are the
plates are pretty much taken care of but
not the placards
so I would support this bill if it said
that you could have as many license
plates as you want but only one
placard because uh the the situation
reparo gave about his dad uh having
problems going to the airport parking
his truck but yet he still needed
his um placard to take with him to the
state that he was going to be driving a
rental car in that makes total sense so
if his truck had had a plate on it
disability plate that problem wouldn't
have started to begin with
but my main concern is if we expand if
somebody has 10 Vehicles they want 10
plates because right now I've got four
vehicles and I've only got one plate on
her van my ve my four vehicles that I
drive none of them have plates so I
constantly have to make sure I've got my
placard with me um so I would support it
for plates but the placers should be
limited to one placard because I see no
reason why you should need more than one
placard and then we ought to bring the
system down to what my wife said like
Illinois did and and we should recall
all the placards start from ground zero
and you should have a medical purpose
for having that placard and I think also
it might be a good idea to have that
placard listed on your license your
driver's license as an assist of if you
have to wear glasses or if you have to
have some kind of assistant device to
operate the car it should be noted on
there the serial number that's on your
placard should be called out on your
license I think that would help a lot
with people using them that wasn't
entitled to use them thank you very much
any questions any questions from the
committee representative
gon thank you Mr chair thank you sir for
your testimony so am I correct to
understand that if uh if the honorable
pataro would uh amend this to strike and
placards that you and your wife would be
in support of it I would
be I'm sorry I'm not speak for my wife
I'm sorry I I I know I know I know I
know I know better I'll withdraw the
life any other questions from the
committee not see again thank you so
you chair i' like to recognize Kristen
Evans from Abel New Hampshire who's
requesting three minutes who is in
Transportation thank you
um thank you for the opportunity to
testify in support of HB 259 for the
record my name is Kristen Evans and I am
the director of policy for AEL New
Hampshire and Abel is a disability
Justice
organization and we are nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that fights for
the civil and human rights of children
and adults with disabilities I'm here
today to voice strong support for House
Bill 259 this bill is an important step
towards ensuring Equitable access to to
transportation in public spaces for
people with disabilities enabling
greater Independence and mobility in
their daily
lives I sent I gave you my written
testimony so I'm going to be brief so
you can you can review the whole thing
but by passing 259 New Hampshire would
enhance the independence and mobility of
its residents with walking disabilities
ensuring that they have Equitable access
to transportation in public spaces this
legislative change is a necessary step
towards promoting inclusivity and
upholding the rights of individuals with
disabilities in our state and we urge
the committee to support House Bill 259
and recommend its passage and I did want
to address um the placards uh we would
be in support currently of um the
license plates we don't have a a
placards thank you any questions from
the
committee not seeing any thank you so
chair person like chair like now
recognize Jen ba Jen Bailey from the
DMV uh who's requesting three
minutes welcome to trans good yeah okay
good afternoon members of the chair so
DMV is not in support or oppose we're
here more for just informational um
based on some testimony we've heard here
today to answer some of your questions
you've had throughout this so the
placard and plate are tied to an
individual so you have the option when
you have a walking disability
application filled out to either obtain
one plate and one placard or two
placards and then a few years ago it was
changed through legislative process to
add that you can also have an additional
plate on a motorcycle So currently those
are your options to have um addressing
the two members in one household again
it's tied to the individual so if you
have two members of a household who own
one vehicle one member could get one
plate on that vehicle and one placard
the other member could get two placards
so they would have three placards
amongst them in one plate if they owned
a motorcycle they could also get a
motorcycle plate uh we did run some
recent numbers I'm not sure where the
600,000 placards came from um we
currently have on file that there are
132,133
permanent placards and
3,715 temporary placards that are active
currently um so those are the current
numbers that we have um let's see we
have had recent discussions I was
mentioned with the DMV systems about the
placard process and we were working with
the governor's Commission of disability
on different processes with that
whether there is a downfall when someone
misplaces or loses or a placard is
stolen on how that's replaced and so
we've been discussing different
protocols and how we handle that but
that is just a little bit more of
clarification that we want to provide on
the placard process with the
DMB any questions from the committee
representative
syes thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um as this bill is
currently written does that mean that um
and under your current way of operating
um each person could get their own plate
but they would be charged separately for
each plate for each plate correct and
the charge would be uh the plate for
handicap is $8 correct it's $8 for the
plate so it's so so it's only $8 to get
a second plate if you have a second
vehicle if you are have two
people so right now you're not eligible
for a second vehicle this bill is trying
to enact that you are only eligible for
one plate
and one plard for one person for one
person but two people could in fact have
two different plates if you own two
different Vehicles yeah yes thank you
you're welcome representative Hill thank
you Mr chairman thank you for take my
question um temporary plates how how
long uh temporary placards yep how long
are they um maximum six months and it's
six full months so if you apply for it
Midway through a month you're going to
lose half month of time are they
renewable they are renewable with a new
letter from your doctor each time thank
you unlimited
unlimited representative
gon thank you Mr chair ma'am would you
please uh restate the number of
permanent placards in circulation per
year information yep
132,133
thank you representative foot thank you
m thank you um on the placards there's a
number on the bottom to the if a if a
police officer was to look at that could
they ascertain who that belongs to if
they were if they were checking on a
spot they cannot buy the number um
however if you have a walking
disability privilege um it prints a
handicap symbol on your
license okay thank you representative
Fox thank you Mr chair do you have the
number of um
license plates that are issued hand
license plates I do not we do not have
the count of that we could get that for
if you'd like that okay please just out
of curiosity thank you representative
Hill thank you Mr
chairman I'm curious about what you know
of the the placards that you can
purchase on Amazon um is that anything
that anybody is checking up on to see if
you actually can purchase New Hampshire
walking disability placards on Amazon I
do not know that and I have not looked
that up thank you could you we we can
look at
that yeah
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question um what
are some of the protocols that would be
considered to mitigate the lost and
stolen placards like expiration dates or
barcodes or so we have talked about um
so law enforcement uses a program called
spots to look at when you're pulled over
and whether or not we can report that
placard number through there so when you
are looked up again this becomes more of
an Enforcement issue on how law
enforcement were to enforce that um or
as it was mentioned printing either the
placard number on the license or vice
versa printing the license number on the
plaque Ard there's other both those
discussed follow up would it make sense
to put a an expiration date on the
placard so that they are stolen or lost
they're only good for a limited amount
of time so that they can't be so renewed
or that's actually a very good question
um so they actually do expire so even
though they're permanent placards
they're only good for the term of your
license so they match your license so
there are fiveyear expiration dates um
whole punched into them and then every
five years you bring in a new doctor's
note um to have that
reassigned representative foot thank you
m i I'll uh yield
my question was answered thank you any
other questions from the
committee not see
$480 we got two
on you you can buy a an ID number
permanent blackard do they look like the
New Hampshire the blue and white yes
they
do interesting
$480
interesting you can even get them for
your
luggage thank you I feel like this is
the Home Shopping Network right
now representative foot thank you in
light of that question so where the
police don't have access to that now is
there a way to incorporate that so for
these ones that a purchase online that
they can validate that those are
accurate or not um we'd have to do
system changes um spots is a special
program through them where they'd have
to um have the real estate to list that
and then connect with the DMV map system
to pull that information over um so
that's definitely something that can be
looked into Paul follow is there a a
large
monetary to that or this changes it that
would be dependent on how many hours
that work would need it be interfacing
with a program so it could be a few like
$30,000 probably thank you
representative
Crawford thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I've got I'm
curious when they came out with the
placard I was always under the
impression that was a temporary thing so
if you had surgery or whatnot you got a
placard and it lasted for six months
because you couldn't walk and you know
you used it so the the problem here is
is plates I'm assuming because people
are carrying around placards because
they can only get one set of plate for
one person in the household right
so wouldn't it be better to give plates
than to have these placards all over the
place and only issue placards to people
who are temporarily disabled because of
the condition that they have that's
another option so personal experience my
mom has Ms um so she does have plate on
her vehicle and then she carries the
plard with her in her purse for when I
pick her up and take her out so that's
kind of the option of there and it's
opposite right now where the Placer
drives the walking
disability process where you always are
allocated a placard in our system no
matter what and then you can choose to
either get an additional placard or get
a plate on your
vehicle welcome okay any other questions
from the committee not see any thank you
so much thank you and with that I have
nobody else so at this point I will
close the hearing on HP
259 our next bill will be HB 287 which
minutes
all right it's uh
2:37 and I'm G to open the public
hearing
on HB 287 requiring police departments
to provide fire departments with certain
motorist personel and insurance
information following a motor vehicle
incident the chair would like to
recognize representative PR sponsor of
the bill welcome sir I hope your car
of the recer didn't show up for two
hours I called tripa said Hey where's my
recer we don't have that call can we
make it a call now that would be really
great because it's getting cold out here
anyway my name is Mark PR representing
Hillsboro 15 Manchester Ward 8 um so
today I had a fire chief reach out to me
um Tilton
Northfield one of the Departments is
great on giving them information because
if they use Speedy dry or booms or some
kind of consumable they want to be able
to build that back to it
Insurance the other police department
says yeah tough you didn't get it too
bad I ain't giving it to you so he's
just looking for some way to be able to
reach out to a police department and say
hey I need the information from that uh
person and them having to come forward
with you know their name address
insurance company policy number those
kind of things pretty simple they
already have it it's a matter of walking
over to the the copy machine going here
you go right but for some reason some
police departments just don't want to
can't be bothered to furnish that
information so that he's just looking
for a way to make that happen and I kind
of agree with him because we use a lot
of stuff and if we can't get in this day
and age we can't get paid for ambulance
calls
so and now we're losing money on on on
um the things that we have to use for
HazMat and things like that
that's all I
got any questions from the
committee representative
PR thank you Mr chair um thank you for
taking my question why is this
information not a matter of public
record once the police department has it
that's a really good
question but uh it is they just choose
not to go through the effort to readily
make it available some of them
apparently and I I have no idea
why because my Police Department that I
work with I work for eping fire and they
need up follow
up um I'll bet if you made a couple of
91a requests formally that you would get
the information every time that's way
too much
work representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman and thank you repres
representative for taking my question um
if this
passes um and and you make that same
request um from Tilton Northfield uh
which is my fire department by the way
um to uh to the police department and
they say um no and you say it's the law
then what happens then maybe we should
have a penalty if they don't does I'm
glad you brought that up maybe we should
amend it to put a penalty in there you
know I must be a nice guy because I just
think of if there's a law on the books
and we say hey can can we have it that
they would just say yes but you're
probably right they'll probably just say
no um follow up follow up thank you so
let's say that there's a penalty on this
um who's going to enforce it State Polie
how about that AG's office
so we should look forward to an
amendment coming I'd be happy to make
one thank
you I actually have a question okay how
often is this happening so I only have
this one person's
perspective um and like I said one of
those police departments is forthcoming
the other one never does it so depending
on where the accident is
and and I've also kind of heard
grumblings that there's some other
police departments that can't be
bothered as well so it just makes it
more difficult you know and and
sometimes we don't get that information
from that person at the time because
usually the police are yelling at me to
get my big red truck out of traffic so
they can get it moving again so and they
have the license they're getting their
report
information and sometimes I don't have
access to it
and I've gone through back to my Police
Department said hey you got that guy's
information yep sure it's here right
right here here you go but apparently
some other police departments don't want
to play that play
nicely representative Peto thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I forgive me in case I missed
it but could you walk through
um what the need is why would the fire
departments need these details provided
to them by the police department so we
can build their auto insurance for our
consumables like Speedy dry if they dump
a bunch of fuel oil or radiator fluid we
have to put the Speedy dry down pick it
up sometimes we need to put the uh
Hazmat Booms to block SES and stuff so
it doesn't get into the uh drainage
system may I ask to follow up follow up
thank you
um in
in is there any consideration with how
uh an ambulance service ties into to the
fire response are they always integrated
or are they usually separate and is it
based on the town and I only bring that
up because of the the billing aspect as
you so based on the town some of them my
eping is right but we're
getting we don't get their Auto
information we get their
um health insurance right and a lot of
times we don't transport so we don't get
anything we walk up to them hey you okay
or the police wave off the ambulance
because nobody's hurt but the firetruck
stops to check for hazards electrical
fuel oil radiator fluid and any other
such hazards that we have to mitigate uh
so they don't create a bigger problem
down the road thank you
chairman I shut it off I always struggle
with these things
um I just want to make
sure is there additional I don't know
the answer to this which is why I'm
asking the question um is there add are
there additional requirements that would
be necessary under the rsas to allow
fire departments to bill
for ancillary services that like I know
I know they have they can build for
ambulance
services but they there are some things
they can't build for and I'm just I want
to make sure we cover that base if the
as far as I know from the chief that
asked me to put this in when he gets
that information he is billing with
success so I'm assuming it's
thank you I just want to make sure we
cover the base so that it can be done if
it's if if you know we get far enough
along any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much you're welcome thank you and with
that I have nobody else um on the list
for this particular bill so at this
point I'm going to close the public
hearing on HB 287
our next bill is HB 298 which we'll get
minutes
e
it's uh
2:51 I'm going to open the public
hearing on HB
298 creating an exception to the
prohibition on removing Vin tags from
Vehicles manufactured prior to 1981
where removal is reasonably necessary
for repair or
restoration and the chair would like to
recognize representative home who is the
Prime sponsor welcome sir to
Transportation thank you Mr chairman
thank you members of the committee I'm
putting in this bill at the request of a
client of mine client a constituent of
mine from Nashville Nash The Honorable
representative Larry Arts former House
member who has a hobby and a business
restoring antique
cars now the problem when you restore
antique cars is that they get pretty
Rusty and once in a while that rust
comes out to the side of the car where
the name plates
attached and if you got to replace the
piece of rust that has the uh V the vent
plate on it
um then you got a problem trying to move
that vent plate to the repaired part of
the car it's not legal to take a vent
plate off and put it on a different
chassis and technically this is a
different chassis when you repair the
part that had the V plate on it so the
bill is to allow res people who restore
antique Vehicles defined as model year
1981 and earlier to do these kind of
repairs to not just repair the upper
body but to repair some of the chassis
and specifically be able to move the
vent plate to the new
chassis and with that I'd like to turn
the testimony over to uh my colleague
representative The Honorable
representative former representative
Larry
Ys he's next on my list so hold up on
that any questions from the
committee representative gon thank you
Mr chair sir would it make more sense to
put a time uh line rather than a year on
this such as a vehicle 40 years older
older 45 years old or older because it
seems to me that 19881 is a specific
point in time where the definition of
antique is changing as we grow older
every minute it certainly does make
sense uh it used to be 25 years for an
antique car this is over 40 years I go
back to kind of the premission days when
he could actually work on
cars uh but I'll defer that response to
my uh colleague rep uh Mr
hers any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you sir
thank
you with that I'd like to call up uh
Larry Arts who's representing himself
who is in support of the bill welcome
sir to Transportation thank you Mr chair
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Lawrence Arts I live
in Nashua and just a slight correction
and it it I have it's not a business but
a hobby of mine restoring old cars I've
been involved with that uh activity for
many many
years to answer your question
representative about the 1981 cut off
um 1981 was the beginning of the the
standardized 17 digigit Vin format that
all cars all vehicles all motor vehicles
and trailers have to abide by when
they're manufactured and that's why I
requested that the uh the cut off be at
1981 although if if the committee feels
that um 40 years or some other
uh age is appropriate then I have no
problem with
that uh back in the 50s and 60s the see
the original Vin tampering law was
written back at a time when no one
really
foresaw people restoring Motor Vehicles
as
Antiques and also at that
time manufacturers had their own format
their own placement for Vin plates
on these vehicles and as such um now
that a lot of these cars that are being
restored had been sitting in junkyards
been sitting in
fields and just you know through
time they uh they have to undergo some
major restoration and with the
proliferation of replacement parts that
are body parts that that didn't really
exist as a a replacement that are now
available today people are taking a
rusted body and actually restoring the
car General Motors for instance they put
their Vin plates on the a pillar down
behind the door
jam up on the windshield pillar like
they were on the 55 through 7 Chevys or
they would put them somewhere on the
cowl but if that portion of the car
needs to be replaced because it's rusted
or damaged it's going to
NE necessitate moving the VIN
temporarily to be able to repair that
section of the
car and then it gets reattached once the
repair is complete but if you go if you
go by the letter of the law it's
technically an illegal activity and what
happened I'll tell you a little bit of a
incident that happened here a few years
ago there was a man in Kansas who bought
a 1959 Chevy C vet he he actually bought
the car in Indiana but he attempted to
register it in his home state when he
went to get the car inspected the uh
Highway Patrol determined that the VIN
had been removed and then reattached and
then what happened was they impounded
his car as Contraband because they
thought that maybe that the they they
just presumed that the car was stolen
because the VIN did not have its
original rivets or its original
um spot Wells or whatever the case may
be I think on a Corvette because it was
fiberglass they uh riveted it and I'm
not exactly sure because I'm not a I'm
not uh really into the Corvettes per
se and according to Kansas law because
that b had been removed the car would
have had to been
destroyed because it would have been
presumed until he proved otherwise that
the car was not
stolen and uh so as a
result of all kinds of litigation the
car sat outside for
years while this uh issue wound through
the courts eventually he was able to
get he was able to Prevail and he was
able to ultimately register it but it
became a extreme hardship for him and so
Kansas changed their law to basically
the same language of what I've been
proposing to uh to do here for New
Hampshire and um it they also the State
of Arizona which is home to the Barrett
Jackson auctions for classic
cars they amended their law in the same
fashion now federal law allows it but
what I can see in New
Hampshire state
law allows no provision on in the on the
activity of res of removing and
replacing the VIN to inorder order to
facilitate a repair or restoration on
the car and I would like to have that
exemption put in at the same
time the language in the law does not
allow for anybody to conceal the
identity of a car if the if the person
knows that it is stolen you leave those
Protections in place but to just carve
out that exception for the person that's
trying to restore the car
and um needs and needs to be able to
temporarily remove that uh that VIN tag
from the car because a lot of guys a lot
of people they just do it and they don't
tell anybody and you know then they then
nobody says anything and you know they
can go for years and years but all it
takes is just
one one officer or something like that
uh that that's real Eagle eyed and you
know or or you know wants to make a
stink about it and they'll cause a lot
of problems for that person and what
what I would like to do is to avoid that
issue and so if anybody has any
um
questions so any questions from the
committee representative
Peto thank you Mr chair for taking make
uh for allowing me and thank you for
taking my question um as a uh uh autor
restoration
Enthusiast do you have any knowledge or
comments to the idea of like the VIN
number can be found in multiple spots in
this same car I believe we have them on
the door the
dashboard uh the engine block um
do how long has that been a thing where
the VIN is stamped on strategic spots on
the C you know okay different years um I
know that in the late 80s they started
putting VIN numbers
on major body panels like fenders or
bumpers um but going back further like I
know at least with General Motors
Vehicles before
1968 the only other Vin that they had on
at least like on the Chevy Nova that I'm
familiar with because I uh that's the
cars that I'm
into they have a partial Vin stamped at
two places adjacent to each other
underneath the driver's side fender on
the cowl flange but it's only a partial
Vin the first five digits which uh
denote the year and the body style is
not included in there it's just the
plant that it the plant letter
designation and its serial
number
um some of the cars yes they have them
in multiple locations but like I said
but prior to 1968 each manufacturer had
their own methodology and
putting uh VIN numbers on on their car I
know also back in the 40s maybe even the
50s they only put the serial number on
the motor they didn't put it anywhere
else on the car and if you change the
motor you've removed the the VIN number
from the car and then in that case I
don't know what happens do they uh are
they allowed to make a new vin plate or
are they um allowed to um or does the
state have to give you a state issued
Vin and in that case you have this white
sticker that's got the state seal on it
and it gets placed wherever the officer
puts fixes it to the vehicle and it may
or may not be an appropriate place for
the owner to like where it was
put thank you representative a thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question what are the ethics behind
putting an original Vin tag on a on a
body part that's been substantially
repaired if you you had to make a
major patch for the for the part it's no
longer original what how's that viewed
by anti- car collectors and and the
marketplace well you you you you're
repairing that section of the car that
contains that bin plate I mean if it's
just a like on the GM cars the uh the
driver's sight pill or if that got
smashed or if it got rusted and they put
in a new a new piece on there a new you
know section of that car to repair it
the uh the the new piece does not have
any numbers on it if you buy an a pillar
for instance or if you're buying the
cowl the the dashboard or the um the
firewall um it just you're basically
you're repairing that same car of course
you don't want to take the vent plate
off of one car and put it on another
that's not ethical at all but you want
to be able to maintain the VIN number
for that same car that you're restoring
because a lot of these car
enthusiasts they the VIN number will
tell you whether it's an SS whether it's
a a a real GTO or not just a tempest or
it you know it it has these certain
options this type of motor or whatever
and they like to be able to have their
car continue to be matching to the rest
of the car when they restore it these uh
car rest restores they uh they go right
into these details that most other
people don't even think
about representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I think I'm following up on um
representative V's
question would it are you envisioning
some type of a disclosure that would
have to follow the car um like you would
do with a odometer change or something
like that because it seems to me if you
transfer ownership without disclosing
that you have removed this tag and
returned the same tag on there that
someone down the line could get in
difficulty with a Eagle Eye officer as
you're saying I mean it it would seem to
me you'd need to have some kind of chain
or paperwork that would say this has
been removed at some point and replaced
yeah that that that would not be a
problem if there was some kind of an
official uh declaration or an affidavit
or something like that to go along with
the car I would be before
that well um additionally I know when
you homemade trailers or something like
that you need to have someone come and
view uh you know the the local police
officer will come and and view that
there is no or certify that there is no
VIN number and and you end up with that
uh sticker somewhere along the line
would something like that help your
situation that all that someone would
come and certify that the VIN number
plate had been removed and and well that
CH basically changes the VIN number of
the car and it it changes its ientity
and its and its
um I guess you know it's Prestige among
the among the the car collector because
a lot of times those that that VIN
number denotes that whether or not that
was a real super sport whether it really
came equipped with a 327 or was it a 283
car or was it a six-cylinder car whether
or not it uh had you know had a certain
option package or something like that
and I think what that would do if you
had a state issued event it would
devalue the car as far as the car
collector is
concerned Paul thank you I I don't think
I'm saying I'm changing the VIN number
just just the fact that it was the plate
was removed while you repaired that and
then the plate is being put back on so
that it doesn't look like the original
rivet or something like that I would
that not solve your issue if there was a
um if there was like you mean like a a
certificate that went with the car there
you go that that that I wouldn't have an
issue with that okay if that yeah
representative frat yes thank you Mr
chair um following on this
discussion uh I'm not sure that I
understand exactly what the interest of
the State of New Hampshire is
in this
process um clearly a title is not
required for a vehicle that old and in
your mind what would
differentiate uh a 52 Chevy Corvette
from an 1890 Lin dresser which is also
an
antique
well okay you it had two different
questions here I I kind of lost um
I lost my train of thought on the first
part of
that uh the first part of the question
is what exactly is the interest of the
State of New Hampshire because a title
is not required for a vehicle I believe
25 years or
older okay um I got got that part the
state of New Hampshire allows a person
to obtain an antique vehicle title for
Vehicles over 25 years of age it's an
option for the for the vehicle owner and
it also helps when selling that vehicle
to um people out of
state and the state's interest is
that right now it's a crime to just
remove
it to remove that VIN for any
reason and what what this bill would do
is it would eliminate that potential
criminal
offense the second part of the question
the second part of the question is um
again what differentiates a antique 52
chevy from a an 1840 Len dresser which
also has antique value and if you're a
collector you want to know that what
article well the VIN number for for a 52
chevy would have a standard format for a
52 chevy and and the other uh vehicle
I'm which I have no idea um I'm not
familiar with it um piece of furniture
it's a piece of oh a piece of furniture
it probably wouldn't have an A number
that even closely resembles that of a
car I I'm not exactly sure how to answer
that question that's kind of to me
sounds like an apples and
oranges type of question when I'm trying
to compare you know two different things
there okay we'll let it go with that
thank you
representative any other questions from
the
committee not seeing any thank
you cherl now like to recognize Jennifer
o from the DMV who's requesting uh five
minutes welcome to
Transportation good afternoon committee
members thank you for taking the time to
hear me today my name is Jennifer o and
I'm the title bureau administrator with
the division of Motor Vehicles I've been
with the division for 22 years with a
main focus in both registration and
titling of vehicles I've heard your
questions today along with the testimony
regarding this bill and I just wanted to
provide some information and take any
questions you may have regarding this so
when a vehicle whether it be antique or
title required has a VIN removed and
different major component parts added to
it from a vehicle that bears a different
Vin this would be what we consider an
assembled vehicle we would need to see
all documentation pertaining to all
vehicles with major component parts
pertaining to vins regardless of the
year of manufacturer and then we as the
state of New Hampshire through our state
police members would assign a New
Hampshire issued Vin whether it be
titled or not if we have if we are
looking at this bill in a sense where we
are going to remove a plate restore
refinish and then put that plate exactly
back on and we're not taking major
component parts from any other VIN
numbers then that I think would be a
different story and I think there were a
couple questions pertaining both of
those scenarios so I'll just open that
up to you guys if you have any
questions thank you any questions from
the
committee representative syes thank you
so you
just in my mind at least you opened up a
can of worms which I appreciate because
I was wondering about this there's
nothing in this bill as it's currently
written that would be
that would differentiate between those
two different scenarios that you just
described that is correct and and do you
does the New Hampshire
DMV is that is that a problem for the
New Hampshire DMV title bureau with the
language that's in the bill that's
written as is
today it is represented that the VIN
there would be no penalty if the VIN was
removed for restoration and then
replaced not the VIN taken off of this
vehicle that I have sitting here that I
want to restore well I've taken a
chassis that is in much better condition
than the one that I have the chassi is
actually uh one of the major component
parts that has a VIN from another
vehicle so when we talk about the VIN
describing where it was made when it was
made what the model is there is value
added to that and that is what
collectors want to see in the vehicle
but in our eyes when you're meshing
multiple vehicles with multiple vins
together there is a process that we go
through what we don't want to see is we
don't want to see a VIN number for a
frame that's attached to John's vehicle
while that VIN plate on the public
dashboard is taken off and placed onto
another vehicle that opens up for fraud
and what we see there is masking of
vehicles we see this going across the
entire United States we have these
checks and balances put in place that if
you're going to take multiple vins and
merge into one vehicle which we see all
the time we are going to assign a New
Hampshire Vin and we are actually going
to merge those used vins into that so
that if another Vin plate is taken and
it's part of your chassis it's not going
fraud representative Hill so I'm hearing
thank you for taking my question um I'm
hearing that you don't have a problem
I think what you're saying is what
they're asking
for there currently isn't a problem
with removing the penalty for just
removing the VIN and replacing it right
back on the same vehicle would be on the
enforcement side that would not have
anything to do with our process at the
division uh however uh there was a
statement that was made in the testimony
that talked about taking a chassis from
another vehicle as part of the
restoration and that's what would open
up um some issues on our with the
paperwork follow follow up follow thank
you but that's not what the bill is
talking about that second scenario your
your your objection is to the testimony
that we were talking about I'm providing
information on the testimony yes it
sounds to me and maybe I'm wrong but it
sounds to me like if you spoke with the
prime sponsor and uh the gentleman that
testified it sounds like what they want
to do is already available to be able to
no the what what they're asking to do
just in this bin yeah if it isn't in
conjunction with the testimony provided
they would need the verbiage in here
because it is current they are correct
that if you remove a VIN regardless if
you're replacing it for whatever reason
it is part of the penalty got it thank
you you're
welcome representative a thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um so
the scenario if you you have a rusted
out uh Fender and you take the tag off
from inside the fender and you repair
that that area you weld in a new piece
of Steel and you you is it okay to put
that tag back on right that's not legal
right
now um no if if that sounds like that's
what they're trying to achieve for
models 81 or older in this language that
that scenario yeah I guess it's more of
a question followup follow more of a
question for collector or an offici AO
to how would that be perceived in the
marketplace if you know it's the same
Fender but it was repaired and the tag
put back on what that I I would not be
able to provide that thank you
representative Martin uh thank you Mr
chairman uh and thank you for appearing
uh it surprises me there is not more
detailed federal law in this area are we
sure that we're not stepping on anything
Federal when we do this that is a
fantastic question uh we can reference
CFR our 49 CFR uh to see if this would
be um in violation of that I know that
these are our New Hampshire enforcement
laws right
now representative
patero thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um you mentioned
briefly the concept of an assembled
vehicle can you um explain in more
detail like what that is and like what
to expect with the state giving a new
vin to an assembled vehicle yeah
absolutely that's a great question thank
you so if I take my
1996 Honda Accord um it does not require
a title but it has a valid issued Vin
and I take the frame of a 1990 Honda
Accord and uh remodel the vehicle
whether it be due to damage whatever
it's what I could find at the scrapyard
the size matches there are going to be
VIN numbers issued to both of those
Vehicles both of those Vehicles will
have chain of transfer right transfer of
ownership that you're going to
see the issue becomes that where these
VIN numbers are placed on different
component parts and now these vehicles
are essentially being parted out and put
together we need to create one single
VIN number and essentially kill off the
other bin numbers so that those aren't
being used fraudulently
world representative Fox thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question and this is kind of
hypothetical because I'm not versed on
antique cars at all but I know the VIN
number in my vehicle now is on a plate
on the dash if I were to own an ant a
vehicle older than
1981 with the VIN number there let's say
hypothetically and I needed to replace
that dash for some reason I wanted to
remove the the VIN number put a new Dash
in replace the VIN
number under the law current law I can't
do that that is correct under the new
law I would be able to do that that is
correct thank
you any other questions from the
committee
nope not seeing any thank you so thank
you for your time and with that I have
nobody else um on the docket so at this
point I'm going to close the public
hearing on HB
298 our next bill would be HB 326 we'll
our
good to see you I'm sorry you didn't ask
that's
okay it's 3:22 I am going to open up the
public hearing on HB
326 which is prohibiting the operation
of antique passenger vehicles model year
1968 or older on state or or local
highways for more than 20 miles unless
the vehicle is fitted or retrofitted
with seat or safety belts
at this point i' like to chair like to
call up representative Tim haran yes
sponsor of the bill welcome
Transportation I'm I'm resident Timothy
Horan from straford County District 10
the town of Durham and um I subed here
several times the last session so many
so like uh one person asked me oh are
you on transportation again I said like
no I was on Judiciary but uh and this
bill um it was a suggestion from a
friend of mine whose brother was killed
in a in an accident and I think probably
uh uh I I've seem to I I think the
anti-ar collecting Community doesn't
like the bill as as written and um so
that's uh I just have to acknowledge
that up front and they're compared to
some of the other uh other lobbies have
inspired the IR of um I feel a little
bit bad about that because they're very
they all seem to be very nice and
cheerful people so unlike some others
I've inspired the IR of but anyway I'll
start
um so first off the first piece of
testimony here which was uh which was
from a friend
who uh suggested it to me it was uh Kate
Miller from Meredith who's actually a
former State Rep served uh from 200 9 to
2010 and um her brother was an antique
car ficado so I guess I'll read her
statement it would probably be much
better if if she was here she's a much
better speaker much better writer than
me but anyway she says my brother John
Warner IV was an antique car and
airplane defishing AO he maintained a
garage in Melbourne Village which is a
gathering spot for fellow old car
junkies to trade advice and tell tall
stories um something she didn't add to
was that the name of his garage was
actually the Melvin garage so that was
but on a particularly sparkling New
Hampshire day two years ago in June John
decided a quick errand would be the most
fun if taken in one of his antiques with
the top down not far down the road we
presume he saw an oncoming car drifting
across a center line that driver post
accident recalls hearing a horn and then
seeing a white light that light
apparently was the impact of my car
hitting my brother's vehicle with enough
force that he was ejected killing him on
on upon
impact this fanciful anti car neither
seat belt nor automatic steering nor
brakes and yet it was legally registered
in New Hampshire since it was in the
antique category if New Hampshire
require seat belts for all individuals
under a certain age parenthetically I
believe that's 18 why does it not in
vehicles in vehicles over certain age
I'm sure the statistics are low for
access in category but they're not low
in my family so and then um my testimony
which I put on the portal but I don't
think I have emailed to you um and maybe
I'll uh this bills inspired the death of
a wonderful man who dialed suddenly much
too soon a car crash near his home in
Melvin Village two years ago John Warner
IV um his obituary sites a very specific
time 1:44 p.m. June 12 2023 he was
driving one of his many treasured
antique Vehicles when he died on an
otherwise ordinary Monday afternoon I
mean it was sparkling but
ordinary the old car did have a horn and
he was able to honk it before the other
driver hit him but it lacked a number of
other modern safety features including
seat belts the accident likely would
have been a minor one if he'd been
wearing a seat belt I guess not everyone
behind me is going to agree with that
but um but it became a tragedy I'm
introducing this bill because I don't
want any other families to go through
what John Warner's family is going
through since 20123 and um he did um he
did many great things in his hometown of
Clinton Illinois about 160 Mi south of
Chicago in New Hampshire's Lake Region
and elsewhere so here in New Hampshire
is probably best known for leadership
role at the W Museum of World War II at
Wolf Baro which I place I'm sure many of
you visited um Everybody in the room
should visit that place it's a one of
the most interesting museums in New
Hampshire so he took a keen interest in
the vehicles articles and other items on
displ museum I know him uh better as the
brother a former State represent Kate
Miller John didn't always wear a seat
belt U but his sister always wears her
even though she lives in New Hampshire
where seat belts are optional this bill
was based on her suggestions so my
original idea was to ban all pre 1968 SE
seat BS cars in the highway but that
that's obviously extremely excessive and
um in theory um 1968 that was the 1967
model year when the federal law was
passed making C belts mandatory um they
and I think there aren't any cars post
1968 which lacked seat belts unless you
know some strange thing happened so and
and uh seat belts they were not they're
fairly common place even before the 1968
model year and the now standard
retractable three-point shoulder belt
which we all have in our cars and
hopefully everybody in the room actually
uses theirs um that was invented in 1959
by a Volvo engineer named Neils Boland
in 19659 and quickly spread worldwide
and
um then I have like a little paragraph
here I'll skip over about my dad's 1963
Ford Falcon which uh had front lap belts
as standard equipment you can actually
still get seat belts and then my mother
is having aftermarket lap belts
installed in the back anyway it's a very
short de detail Bill the details of
implementing might well obviously we
need a lot more detail than what is
shown here and that was why I asked to
give the do rulemaking Authority and
probably um there is um well I'm um be
pleasantly surprised if this idea goes
too far but like uh there are other
states that have laws in that California
is a very extensive one which uh
anyway so anyway whatever you do at this
bill I hasten to add that even if you do
pass it um it merely changes
requirements for making pre-1968 cars um
you know from before the 1967 from the
1966 model year and older um street
legal doesn't change our existing laws
about wearing seat belts if you are an
adult you still wouldn't be actually
legally required to wear your car's seat
belt no matter how old the car is and
I'm guess I'll also say at the end this
is this is probably a difficult year to
be introducing any seat belt bill you
know even though um even when we had
this baate of accidents in I95 uh the
former Governor you know said they're
going to en Force the laws on distracted
driving and U well we don't have a state
seat Bel law so they couldn't enforce a
non-existent law but like he didn't even
urge people to buckle up but um
so so anyway that that's the bill I
think there's a good idea there I
certainly my ideal preference would be
have the committee retained it and work
it because I probably need more than
just the 20 miles unless you're going to
a parade or a car show so even if so you
wanted to accommodate uh anti- car
collectors uh you probably would need
you probably need more exceptions of
what's in the bill and um so that uh
that's that's my bill and former
representative Miller's testimony and
wish she would have been better if she
was there she would have delivered it
much better than I did but so I'm happy
to take any questions any questions for
the committee yeah representative G yeah
I'm going to have a question and a
followup um thank you Mr chair so my
initial question is yeah
um are you aware of what this would do
to the value of the of the vehicles that
would be modified in terms of their
collectibility and their appraisal
initially and are you aware also that
this would um trigger actually a
criminal action for people coming over
the Border who do not have to face these
restrictions as collectors were they
coming to a car show u i I guess guess
the law I mean the second thing that's
something you could you could put if you
like the bill except for that one thing
um you could put an exception for
vehicles registered from out of state
and um so um looking at the wrong
looking at this other Bill let's
see yeah it does refer to all antique
passenger vehicles regardless of where
they're registered so that's U you know
if you just want to change it definition
of what a street legal vehicle is and
tweak the definitions or create another
class of antique Vehicles you could do
that I think that's what they did in the
California law although I haven't had a
chance to I looked at a few weeks ago
but I Haven a chance to look at that so
that's
uh yeah that's for the value that's
decision you can make we did as I said
we did put in least we already put in
like some exceptions anyway so you don't
have to if you don't want to put one in
your car uh you you you don't have to I
think the one involv bomed in the
accident was a roadster from the 1940s
from what I've heard from somebody else
who seen the police report and that you
know I don't know whether that would uh
I think probably some people did have
crude seat belts back then but some
didn't yes all yes and and don't get me
wrong I sympathize with these losses um
individuals have the right to make these
modifications should they so choose but
my followup is specifically to uh
traffic enforcement without the police
going on a fishing Expedition when they
pull somebody over they don't know how
long you've been on a public roadway for
where you're coming from where they're
going to um to me I I believe that this
would create a set of circumstances
where you would have an expectation of
the police to do um basically an
unwarranted deep search how would this
be enforced in your opinion um I that's
probably a question you should either
ask of someone else or you have a work
session to get into that detail I
believe this is um this is something
would probably be enforced you know at
the time of at the time of registration
so they have to add some sort of
endorsement to the registration um
that's uh that's one of the many issues
why we gave dot rulemaking Authority in
this bill to hash out those details or
you can try to Hash them out in a work
session or even the retain Bill during
the summer should you should you want to
pursue this idea at all so any other
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much and uh chair would now like to
recognize uh Richard Smith representing
himself um who opposes the bill who was
asked for uh three minutes uh welcome
Transportation Mr chairman uh thank you
for uh letting me speak today my name is
Richard Smith I'm a lifelong resident in
the state of New Hampshire and I
currently live in
B I've been active in the antique and
classic automobile hobby since I was in
high school personally I've owned a
total of five different Model A Fords
and I've participated in at least six
total
Restorations I'm currently president of
the White Mountain chapter of the Model
A Ford Club of
America our chapter has over 70 family
members most of which are somehow
engaged in the antique car
hobby many of our Members Own more than
one model A or several antique cars of
models a large percentage of our cars
are restored and maintained by their
hobbyist
owners we are proud to represent a
portion of several million old Fords
still in use
today only slightly newer but like our
model T brother
our cars are made to be
driven they are meticulously maintained
usually by their owner to safety
negotiate the scenic back roads of
byways of New Hampshire and New
England for
years antique automobiles were subject
to State of New Hampshire safety
inspections equipment not provided by
the manufacturer such as directional
signals seat belts electronically contr
control braking systems
airbags and a multitude of other post
manufacturing
improvements were not required of our
vehicles on the other hand safety is an
important concern of any antique owner
and Driver we know seat belts provide a
significant benefit to the driver and
the passenger of modern
vehicles I'm however I'm not aware of
any data indicating seat belts or other
Technologies are needed to lower the
injury rates specific to antique
automobiles in the state of New
Hampshire despite that many of our
antique owners have added turn signals
improved lights and other safety
features which include seat belts uh to
their vehicles these features when
present have been added at the will of
the owner and not because of unnecessary
regulation I'd like to take a couple
minutes and
at the end here and just go over some
technical
issues uh and then I'll explain why we
think HP 326 should not become
law the early automobile industry relied
heavily on Carriage or coach
manufacturers to supply the bodies for
the fledgling automobile
companies therefore wood was often the
primary structural
material even the body styles made by
Ford
made completely by Ford contain wood
subframes wood seat frames and wood
floorboards this fact makes installation
of safety belts a challenge that is
likely to exceede the skills of the
average
hobbyist the Advent of federal seat belt
regulations requiring installation at
the time of manufacturer ensured that
the engineering would be correct and
consistent this will be a tall order for
a retroactive installation
HP 326 specifies the installation and
use of seat belts or safety belts the
term seat belt or safety belt to the
average owner of the modern automobile
knows that this
includes the shoulder
belt if HB 336 intends to require a
shoulder belt a great number of antique
ERS will
need major structural changes to make
that
happen Cas in point
would be any of the open
cars okay next I'd like to address
cost designed and installed at the
factory allowed the cost to be
transferred to the buyer at a much lower
per unit cost than possible on a
one-of-a-kind
basis retroactive installation will only
work if the state cares to engineer and
regulate the design and then inspect
each installation to ensure its
compliance
surely there would have to be a fee for
inspection added to the cost of the
Professional installation therefore
substantially increasing the financial
burden to the
hobbyist lastly
enforcement how would HB 326 be enforced
would antique Autos be pulled over by
law enforcement to determine if the
documents were wearing the seat
belts will only Autos registered
after 19 68 uh or excuse me will only
Autos registered as antique be the
Target or will officers be trained to
recognize any registered vehicle older
than
1968 so they won't inconvenience
occupants of newer Vehicles who don't
even have to wear their seat
belts it's logical to assume that some
type of inspection will be
required to ensure the belts are
installed correctly and who will train
and designate those professionals
to summarize I believe the antique
automobile Community will agree that the
HP 326 is technically deficient
unenforceable
impracticable discriminating and
needless reg
regulation in fact it's likely that New
Hampshire would be the only state in the
State of the Union that requires it I
assume HB 326 was written without the
aid of statistical data relevant to the
frequency of traffic accidents involving
antique
Autos so I can only
conclude that law enforcement resources
and our tax dollars would be more useful
if directed to more effective existing
regulations and we know what they are
the speed limits impaired and distracted
drivers reckless driving Etc thank
you any questions from the committee
representative Peto thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
you mentioned um a situation where with
these antique cars um the state doesn't
have a requirement for certain um safety
features you mentioned specifically turn
signals as wondering if um if you could
expand a little bit on um how how the
breakdown of of those regulations are
whether they're purely Federal if it's
on a state-by-state basis I'm talking
about like tail lights and turn signals
like the third red brake light for
example like like how is you as a Model
A enthusias tackle those and make sure
you're tackling it so everyone's
satisfied I'm not sure I understand the
the total uh scope of your question
but dire turn signals or directional
lights are a good
example uh to to help answer NE your
question there are uh equipment
available for antique cars that can can
uh provide that s uh feature and it it's
easy to
install uh the companies will give you
good directions we're even using uh LED
lights now or bulbs and in tail lights
and so forth all of those things can be
done without remarkably changing the
character of the vehicle and
this uh speaks to the
value they can be put on by a hobbyist
without any
problem there are actually there are
seat belt kits
available but interesting enough if you
purchase one the there are no Specific
Instructions how that should be
installed
correctly if you call the manufacture
they will refrain from advising you of
how to install it and that giv gets back
to my point about in order to have the
seat belts effective and safe they need
to follow Federal Regulations or
somebody's regulations and the average
hobbyist is is not likely to be able to
do that even though many of our people
already have installed seat belts on
their own accord and my point is that's
the way it should be done on our own
accord we don't need it regulated we
don't need all the extra expense
associated with it if we design to have
them we'll put them
on follow thank you um so along those
lines um are you aware of a federal law
or regulation as it pertains to seat
belts for antique Autos yeah not thank
you any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
you chair now would like to recognize
lawen
Arts um who opposes the bill who's
looking around five minutes welcome back
sir thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Lawrence Arts from Nashville New
Hampshire I own a couple of antique
vehicles in 19 51 Ford Custom sedan
which was an original car that I didn't
actually look for the car the car kind
of found me and it was uh inside of a
garage since
1970 and I also own a 63 Chevy 2 Nova
station
wagon right now I'm my station wagon's
undergo
restoration and I was looking at putting
seat bels into that
car I had the whole interior taken
out and I'm analyzing the B pillar if I
were to put seat belts in that
car I'm going to have to put some kind
of a reinforcement inside the
billar which means I'm going to have to
cut into
it put in some kind of an e/ inch plate
with a threaded hole or a nut welded on
the back side and somehow install it
into that b pillar without distorting
the B pillar from
welding and try to make it look
nice but I looked at that I looked at
that pillar and said boy I don't want to
the paint is so nice on the inside of
that car I don't want to touch
it if I screw it up if I make a mistake
it's going to look awful when I when I
put it together but the thing is you
have in order to put seat bels in that
car it takes it takes a lot of thought
and and and planning on how to do it and
you know I want to I'd like to put seat
bels in that car but I don't it's it's
too much it's too much involved to do it
and then I looked at my 51 Ford my
original 51 Ford the B pill is curved at
the bottom and and uh I don't know how I
would make a mount for that there's no
crossmember underneath it I can't fasten
I have to I have to have something
strong underneath if I just go ahead and
bolt seat belts to the floor I get into
an accident they'll just rip right out
of that sheet metal there has to be some
kind of a reinforcement installed in it
which means I'm going to have to
fabricate something and so I am opposed
to this bill and the other thing is it
starts setting a precedent if you start
retroactively
mandating especially equipment in cars
then they're going to start mandating
dual pot Master cylinders antilock
brakes um side marker lights head
restraints um padded
dashboards even
airbags and you know it just won't end
it won't end and pretty soon you have a
car that that that you can't even
recognize from the original car and it
kind of defeats the purpose of having an
antique car for having the uh unique
features that it does have so for those
reasons I am opposed to this
legislation thank you any questions from
the committee representative gon yes can
you please speak to um the question of
what the value of that vehicle is right
now any of those vehicles in your
collection Vice what the value would be
with these modifications what would your
loss on your investment potential as a
collector
be with the modifications made I
mean fully restored
uh Chevy 2 I've seen them as high as
like 24 $25,000 they probably would you
know 15 18,000 it's kind of hard to put
a number on it because you know really
the value of the car is uh what one's
willing to pay for it and I'll tell you
they'll get good money if the car was as
original as can be and not all cut up
and
modified any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much
okay I now like to recognize Chris
Landry representing themsel who are
who's opposed to the
Bill thank you Mr welcome to the welcome
to Transportation my name is Chris
Landry I'm from Hudson uh New Hampshire
45 year resident of uh New Hampshire I'm
currently the president of the central
New Hampshire model te Club um I have uh
four cars that I own that are uh model
year 1930 or earlier so pretty familiar
with the antique um as as n been
mentioned those of us in the antique car
Community are are um very concerned
about safety we do a lot to make sure
that our cars are safe to drive we like
to drive them we obviously don't want to
get an accidents within our club and I
know some of the other clubs we actually
have um Tech sessions sometimes where we
will get the club members together and
go over and and you know put it up on a
lift and say you should be checking this
you should be checking this and um also
has already been mentioned um a lot of
us have added stuff to the cars um to
make them much safer in the Model T
world that's usually directional signals
um better braking systems better
lighting things like that um those um
things can mostly be added to the car in
a way that they could be removed okay
and generally um have neutral uh impact
on the value of the car or increase the
value of the car because they're not
really destroying the car as it is as
it's original um but that said um even
um even with our our focus on safety we
don't believe that this proposed bill
for seat belts um is is is a wise idea
there's a number of points that like to
make um about that um one is a couple
points are kind of technical one one
says in the in the bill it says that um
the section is not intended to supersede
any other law requiring the use of seat
or safety belts um and um there's it's
RSA 26 266 62a says any motor vehicle
whose model year 60 years or old shall
be ex from all motor vehicle equipment
and inspection requirements if the motor
vehicle is equipped as it was
manufactured or in accordance with the
motor vehicles original equipment
specifications so that seems to be um in
conflict and would make this
unenforceable and it kind of answers
your question earlier um the cars are
generally required to be equipped as
they were when they were manufactured so
if a car if there's no requirements for
directional signals at the time the car
was manufactured there's no requirement
to have it now you can still stick use a
hand signals out your window if you want
to although that's a very common
modification because we want to be seen
um as you know uh New Hampshire only
requires seat belt use for um persons
younger than 18 years old um this
proposed Bill States all people in the
car is no exception for um for any age
so that seems to be a discrepancy as
well um ALS so in New Hampshire any
vehicle that's 25 years old or older can
be registered as an antique but when you
do register a car as an antique there
are certain restrictions that come with
that as to where you can use it you know
you can't use it as your daily driver
for example if it's an antique car so
some people with cars that are 25 years
or older um choose to do standard
registration instead of antique
registration because they want to use
them more as a normal car um there's no
definition in this proposed bill as to
what you know where would the where the
enforcement be if you have a 1960 car
that you're daily driving is not antique
register does that count as an antique
car or not you know and where there's a
lot of uh sort of enforcement actions
there um that are kind of
difficult um the next Point uh HP 326
proposed HP 326 refers to the applicable
standards in USD um 49 CFR 571 207 to
210 for seat belt requirements and that
raises a lot of issues um
49 C 57128 which talks about what safety
equipment needs to be installed in cars
um only talks about cars from January
1st 1972 on so there's there's no
reference in there for any older cars so
when you talk about app applicable
standards from those cfrs are there even
any applicable standards or how does
that you know reference it it seems to
be um quite a conflict
there um 571 207 is really about seat
installations and how the seats are are
mounted cars and stuff like that and
that includes a lot of requirements um
around longitudinal lateral Force
testing and things like that um you know
it's like 20 times the weight uh you
know the seat structure has to hold seat
latches and stuff like that stuff that
would be um virtually impossible to
achieve in a car that wasn't designed
for that you can't just modify the seat
the whole car structure has to be
designed around those requirements and
and they're not going to be able to um
uh to be met in a modified antique car
um as was mentioned the structure of
many antique cars is not at all like a
modern car um it was very common um back
in the day that the car body um was not
even made by the the branded car
manufacturer they were added after or
there was a in in the case of four they
they were importing um bodies from a
couple different cars and they put on
there a lot of the body structures are
wood um there simply are not seat belt
anchor points in these cars um that you
you you know you can't bolt it down the
floorboards that that are only held in
by a couple sheet screws or something
like that you know that's not going to
hold anything at all um so it's it would
be next to impossible to mount seat
belts that would meet the requirements
of 571 210 it just it just doesn't
exist they're also in in that whole
section that whole group of uh the cfrs
um there extensive testing requirements
for how these things are tested which
makes a whole lot of sense if you're
designing a new car and and you're going
through that testing but I've no idea
how that would be accomplished if you
were trying to retrofit an old car a lot
of that destruct that that testing is
destructive um so you know if you put a
seat belt in and you and you and you
pull on it and it doesn't quite meet the
requirements and it rips the car apart
you know that that really is
incompatible with a custom um
application that's going to be done um
car by
car um we also think if would be next to
impossible to find a shop that would be
willing to do any kind of sheet Bel
installation like this um due to
perceived liability you know if a shop
um you know there's some really good
shops that work on antique cars in New
Hampshire um but if if a car was brought
to them and say hey here's this new law
I need to have seat bels in store inall
this card to meet these Federal
standards I'm pretty sure all the shops
would decline to do that um because if
that car is in an accident and someone
was hurt or injured um or or even killed
um worst case um the lawyers are going
to be coming back to that shop and say
hey you didn't really do it right and
that that's a liability they're not
going to um want to take on and I
believe the state would also face the
liability as well um if the state's
required an installation to something
that was essentially impossible to
achieve and there was a serious accident
um the the the state may may um May face
some liability as
well um as far as um and next
point the older cars especially the cars
I'm familiar with tend to be a little
bit top heavy so they're somewhat
susceptible for rollover accidents you
know we you know we're not out driving
on the highways and things like that so
we we really accents are pretty rare but
I've heard of that um prior to at least
1930 the most popular car types were
what they call touring and roadsters
it's basically what you today call a
convertible right and there is no roller
protection in those cars so if you were
in a rollover accident and I've seen
some pretty horrible pictures and you
were builted in you're guaranteed to be
crushed by that car okay so you know
there's definitely a trade-off right you
know if you've thrown from the car
that's not good either but if there's a
2,000 pound car sitting on top of you
upside down that's not going to be good
at all um even the closed cars um again
you know they look a lot stronger but
they're not designed for rollover they
just weren't back then so um you know a
closed car and a roll over accid is
probably going to give you more
protection than an open car but it's
it's not to give you the protection of a
um H the proposed HB 326 in the fiscal
note um it says that there'll be no
Financial impact at the state county or
local level um we don't think that's
true um there's a lot of uh antique car
shows and tours that happen in the state
every year um a couple of examples
there's a a a very big show at Castle in
the clouds every fall that that pulls
hundreds of cars from all over the state
and even out of state um the horses
Carriage Club has a brass and gas Court
uh tour every year every other the year
that typically goes through New
Hampshire and there's a lot of local
shows um that that are fundraisers for a
lot of Charities and it's very typical
for people to drive their empti cars
farther than 20 miles to get there for
me I I've been to cast Claus two or
three times that's a 70 mile drive each
way in a 1915 car um and you know it
which is obviously well out of the um of
of the limit of the uh um the 20 miles
um there also are um many of the clubs
run tours where we'll get a bunch of the
cars together and run a tour around New
Hampshire and go visit some tour spots
and stuff like that and those tours can
easily be 50 or 100 miles or more um so
a lot of that stuff would probably just
not happen if this was a requirement
because people would not be doing these
modifications to the car and that has an
impact on on the um you know on
fundraising for people on um on other
businesses that are are being patronized
by people on these tours and stuff like
that um despite the fact that there have
been some accidents in in these cars
they're it's not common um you know we
we know obviously in the community is
pretty close and we know of accidents
have happened we know if accidents have
happened outside of New Hampshire um
it's unfortunate but it's not not a
common occurrence um you know we're not
putting the kind of miles on these cars
you put on your modern cars um we're
driving them in appropriate areas in you
know in cars from the the 20s and stuff
we're we're not out on the highway with
them we're on the back road and stuff
like that so accidents do happen but we
don't think that is um that the lack of
seat belts is really um creating a big
safety issue and um I don't know if you
remember from the very early days of
seat bels back in the 60s and 70s um you
know a lat belt only um offer some
protection but you know some in some
cases it it held you in place while you
get slammed into the steering column and
stuff like that so there's definitely a
trade-off there right and we're not
trying to argue that driving antique
cars is safe there's definitely a safety
trade trade off with driving these cars
but it's something that everyone's aware
of and we're trying to make it as safe
as possible and we don't believe that
adding seat belts is going to help that
um and just one final Point um you know
it's been discussed a little bit is that
part of the value of anti cars is
related to their originality right and
um as I talked a little bit about here
there is there is no way that you could
add seat bels in a 1915 car or even a
1960 car without major structural
modifications um it the the car
structure is just not designed for that
and and it would um uh you know someone
asked a question before about the value
I there's no market for cars that are
modified that way so it's very hard to
say what the um what the value would be
if the car was modified that way but if
I add and and one thing in a mod to you
can add aftermarket dis brakes on that
car that doesn't reduce the value of the
car because they're very easy to take
off if someone wants to buy it for
originality
and in some cases that's seen as a
safety feature that that increases the
value of the cost so that's that's a
whole different level of thing so um I
think that the the significant
structural modifications that would be
made uh have to be made to an anti car
to add seat bels that would meet all
these standards um just makes it um
impossible and I think most owners would
opt not to do that and would be limited
to where they can drive their cars and
stuff um so it it seems that HP 326 has
been proposed without really fully
considering all this stuff um we don't
think that this is the right approach um
to to addressing safety in antique cars
and um we hope that this bill is is uh
is is not passed so thank you any
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much before I close out the hearing I
see some people standing and sitting in
there do you want to add anything
because I have no more cards left before
I close the
hearing on this
bill I will I need a I need a pink C
one we can fill out afterwards for
present Pro just let me
know can make it short and quick it be
pretty great I'm a True Believer on the
three minute rule so I own a 67 Mustang
and pretty much all he said was right on
it changes the value of the vehicle and
whatever and if I remember right we were
the last state to go to seat belts
oh right but before that we fought that
too
so why are we trying to impose this on
old cars that I know when I drive my
67 I'm very careful with it I know other
people aren't around me
but so it so I really don't think we
need to be forcing people to put seat
belt in cars that some of them don't go
very fast anyway but just my two cents
and I appreciate
your letting me
speak okay with that I don't have any
other any other slips so at this point
I'm going to close the public hearing on
HB
326 um just a couple of close uh kind of
items for the committee first of all
thank you for your support today with
chairman Walsh beinging of and me taking
over the helm I appreciate you all and
your support uh want to thank uh
representative Martin and Fred for
joining us today and being part of us uh
for everyone else watch your emails
representative uh chairman Walsh should
I call him Vice chair Walsh
okay chairman Walsh will'll send out an
email about next week about hearings and
about exec sessions so watch out for
your email so than that we wish him much
health we'll see you all next
week we have a meeting next week are we
here next week I'm pretty what I'm
pretty sure watch your email it may
change